there's no time
the time is thirteen o'clock
okay here we are finally god damn it
i know it was only like five or six
minutes but it seems like forever
because i had to like restart everything
i feel like the first like
the first like five or ten minutes of
our every single live stream is just us
going like
what the [ __ ] is going on with this [ __ ]
complaining about that [ __ ]
complaining about this [ __ ] laughing
it's not new
yeah it's pretty new i mean it was my
okay so my settings are still okay with
the yeti
your volume good volume good everybody
yeah i think it should be
all right it should be all right bought
a new uh microphone boom for the dam
so it wouldn't just so yeah stick that
[ __ ] sitting there he wants it to be
wanted to be up above us so we have like
a boom might come in there like an
edward movie that'll mean
[Laughter]
yeah i don't know what what's wrong with
this [ __ ] i don't know it's gonna be a
good show tonight though
yeah yeah do you do you know anything
about this nothing about this i just
know that it's about a florida man
yeah this is i'm not in florida man all
right even even though
he is originally from louisiana so you
know that's what i mean he's originally
from louisiana and
this it's weird because i feel like i
kind of have a little bit of a personal
connection to this particular case
because
it happened in 1990 like the um
the autumn after i graduated from high
school and a bunch of my friends
that graduated with me went to the
university of florida
um and so they were like worried when a
lot of them like came home
like when this [ __ ] was going on because
it was at the university of florida
campus
they're all piling in right now yeah
there you go all right
what are we saying about the university
campus yeah so so a bunch of my friends
had gone there
and they were about to start the
semester when this [ __ ] started
happening
and a lot of them either were like
freaking out or they came home
uh you know like until they caught the
dude which took a little while
but the weird thing about it is i feel
like he's one of the lesser known serial
killers
this is like so [ __ ] up to say but
he's like one of the lesser-known serial
killers
even though the [ __ ] he did was like
kind of true it was like he did like
some ted bundy [ __ ]
okay you know what i'm saying yeah look
forward to it
in a weird fashion it's just it's so
[ __ ] up and it's [ __ ] up too because
uh you know spoiler alert for a long
time there was one guy that was a
suspect
and man that i remember it too that
bitch's face was all over the [ __ ]
news and everything like that and it
turned out he didn't do it
like he wasn't a fantastic person but he
wasn't a murderer
right you know what i mean and so he
still he kind of got
saddled with that [ __ ] like even after
they caught the
the real guy so that was like kind of a
[ __ ] yeah kind of a [ __ ]
yeah yeah that's okay but you know i
have well i think
i have about uh an hour hour and a half
worth of notes
but knowing how this [ __ ] goes
it'll probably be like twice as long as
yeah i'm gonna keep my mouth shut
no you don't have to it won't be that
bad all right
the seat listen we got with us they're
still coming in at least we're only
doing one case
yeah i wanted to kind of i'm glad
everybody kind of picked this one
because i've been wanting to do this
case for a long time because i said i
feel like a lot of people don't know
about this guy
and this is somebody that like i i
remember like calling my friends
and being like holy [ __ ] like are you
coming home like what the [ __ ] because
everybody's getting murdered up there
and uh you know and it was scary [ __ ]
like i said it was like you know
pretty much like the worst serial killer
[ __ ] you can imagine like somebody just
breaking into your house and killing you
at [ __ ] random
and [ __ ] mutilating you and all doing
all kind of horrible [ __ ] and it's like
just
yeah no need for me to said he just made
it he's a little bit high on mushrooms
that's okay aggressive it's all right
mushrooms so yeah just just colors man
yeah we'll probably be like pretty trash
by the end of this
yeah um david jews
want to ask me something about advice
about women he wanted advice on women
and some
ex that ex that's kind of trying to a
flirty ex that still wants the d
trying to get some dick off of him i
don't really know what kind of advice i
could give you
like you know make sure you take a
shower
thank you tom you're so helpful yeah
pull the foreskin back clean
if unless if you're uncut
[Laughter]
having a conversation with him we're
trading pictures of a girlfriend's boobs
yeah he was telling me about that right
before the show
they had clothes on them yeah they were
like yeah you know
so i'm sitting there going what are you
doing yeah and i was like well you know
he's like yeah my girlfriend's got good
boobs too
so we're at it you know cough it up
oh well hold on i got to find him you
know i have just pictures ready loaded
inch in the chamber ready to fire
i got 30 30 photographs in the magazine
ready to fire
just in case anyone asks you yeah you're
shooting them out man
yeah yeah sure and see we got brittany
in here
brittany's in here she yeah she's not
saying anything rude yet
says something crazy about me uh tammy
says well it wouldn't be a show if tom
kept his mouth shut
exactly i'm the clown of the show yep
that's another wig you should get yeah
clown wig a red clown
or a rainbow one when i get really
[ __ ] up i'll just put a damn clown wig
on big old
you probably and a nose you need the
nose yeah
yeah i would like to take this
opportunity if you guys haven't seen it
there's a really good horror movie
i think it came out in 2014 2015
something like that
and it's just called clown and it's
about i mean i know there's a lot of
killer clown movies and like lame
but yeah this one was actually really
good it was about a dude who
dressed up as a clown for his son's
birthday party and it turned out that
the clown suit that he
found uh was the skin of a
coin which is like a clown demon yeah
and he couldn't take
it off and then wow and then he started
eating children
it was fantastic and so so yucky i loved
it
make tom up is gacy yeah sure why not
yep i know i'm just oh
i'm so i when the laptop crashed
literally the laptop crashed when i had
you know i have the little starting soon
video on
and as soon as i clicked on the intro
video it went
and it just froze up and i was like
seriously it knows i'm going on vacation
and it's just kind of like
here's one little pain in the ass thing
david was saying that the large the
large
image of the [ __ ] pliskin is a cool
shirt yeah these these are going to be
these are available now well and david
june on the last stream i seem to
remember
that mr victor garcia bought you a shirt
yeah didn't he
i thought he did yeah maybe yeah i don't
know and i and i wrote the name down but
it's like you never got to me with your
address and what shirt you wanted and
[ __ ] like that we have that one we have
the um
what do you call it the uh got a ouija
board one we got the ouija board when we
got the popcorn we got the tyrell ones
that's the one
more human than human yeah genetic
replicants shirt
we got the new 13 o'clock logo shirt
it's good too we got anything
yet we got to make all those i mean if
you're on patreon uh i sent you like i
emailed you pictures of all of them so
you could pick which one you wanted
but uh we got to print them tomorrow and
mail them
i have all the envelopes made out i have
all this [ __ ] you know
britney wants a mason jar with 13
o'clock on it we've got one but it's a
little one
we didn't really make it we made it but
well it's on that
yeah and it's not big enough well they
have a bigger one on there
i think that's just like the regular one
but yeah you gotta look at the size
because
there's a couple different size ones
because i think the one i bought i
wasn't really thinking about it and i
was just kind of like
oh that's little you'd want to get the
big one then it's professionally done
you know jenny designed it and they
executed they make them
we do get a commission off of them so we
do make yeah just not much but just like
a little bit
i've got some [ __ ] on there and like i
said one of our patrons who was in
norway actually requested one of the
zazzle
shirts so i just like drop shipped her
one that was kind of easier anyway
so i don't have to go to the post office
and stand in line
because i like to just use the you know
the self-serve machine
so i don't have to deal with anybody uh
i will say too
oh our one shout out this week is that
we have a new patron
trey and trey has actually been a friend
of the show for a long time always
comments on all our facebook posts and
stuff like that and he was like oh i
finally
became a patron so welcome trey very
nice to have you join our patreon
family i know that sounded really really
queer
yeah trace is saying that shirt is the
one yeah um
i have two versions a smaller one
actually looks really good on
on a smaller frame person but i sent one
out
in like triple triple extra large one
time
and or and or double xl 2xl
3xl and double xl that's what you call
and that image
just did not fill that shirt up it
didn't look
good so i made a bigger version for
bigger shirts but it looks good on on
smaller and medium shirts too this is a
medium shirt
yeah because i figured i mean i don't
even remember why we made the one small
the
what why we made it smaller to start
with i don't know maybe that's what i
wanted
oh well you wanted a smaller okay
because i was sitting there going well
the screen
is like 10 by 14 or so or eight by
something i don't remember how big this
green is it's the perfect size for uh
for a medium shirt
yeah you know what i mean yeah yeah but
it does look nice bigger it looks nice
bigger yeah yeah
i'm gonna make myself one of the ouija
board ones because i really like how
that one came out i was very proud of
myself
when i decided that because it takes me
forever
for some reason when i'm doing graphic
design for other people it's not
that much of a hardship because i can
usually think of something right away
but when i'm
making something for us like for our
show yeah like shirt designs and stuff
it takes me forever like i can't ever
think of anything good
and i always do do like a million
different designs and i'm like i don't
like that one i don't like that one i'm
just like really picky when it comes to
my own [ __ ]
you know what i mean yeah david i think
i think old boy bought you a shirt
yeah yeah victor dead yeah and i'll send
you if you want i'll send you
another one with uh with the big image
on it the biggen
the bigger yeah it was 3xl he was the
one that got the 3xl
i think i have one of those left donna
uh you should i or
like i said i ordered like like 250
worth of shirts of all various sizes
yeah every now and then i just have to
buy another one if we run out but yeah
but if you send us your address i'll
send you another one
yeah yeah it'll be fine like i said i
got all the
envelopes done and i wanted everything i
wanted to mail them all out tomorrow
like before i go on vacation no need for
me too says check your patreon message
yeah yeah yeah what is that what is that
about that's uh
about the uh the laptop oh yeah yeah
okay
yeah i don't know this is a brand new
laptop but it's just not really up to
the task for some reason yeah we just
bought this one like [ __ ] target
because i needed another one and like
you know wasn't the one we wanted
there was another one but they were sold
out yeah so we had to move
down or wrong and it's just it's just
not up to the [ __ ]
it was in the middle that damn pandemic
and it was hard to get computers at that
time
well at least there was a ton of them at
best buy but it's like they didn't
really have the one i wanted there
either yeah
like they had like a bunch of really
expensive ones
but then a lot of the and then a lot of
the cheap ones didn't have what i wanted
and then they're so the mid-price ones
were kind of like
sold out like this pickings were kind of
slim yeah
uh mr roboto says vacation where too i'm
just going to
st augustine florida for a few days
i'm going to chill out going to go to
the alligator farm i'm going to go to
all the museums see all the pirates
and the torture museum and all that kind
of stuff because you know how i do
look at the uh cemeteries
and the fort all that refresh this drink
up
the balance isn't right okay go to the
fudge shop and the bakery
gain 30 [ __ ] pounds probably because
there's like a really lot of
good food there there's like a there's a
bakery there where they
get up every morning it's like you have
to get there really really early if you
want like all the fresh
loaves because they come in the more
they only make so many loaves and if
they're sold they're
usually sold out by like eight or nine
in the morning and they're just like yep
too bad so sad then they close
so you know uh so they have that and
like i said there's a couple shops there
too that make all their candy from
scratch
then you can go in there and there's
like big vats of chocolate and
you can buy the fudge and big boxes but
that was like my favorite thing to do
you know what i mean like when i was a
little kid
a little dessert [ __ ] and so like when
we go to saint augustine my most
exciting thing was like let's go to the
fud shop and we'll get like this big
[ __ ] thing of
like maple white chocolate fudge or
something like that and it's like
[ __ ]
a pound of the [ __ ] yeah it's appeared
oh she has yeah yeah we didn't we
couldn't find her for like a long time
we're looking all over the house going
pokey right so i knew she wasn't out on
the board turn off then
where was she i want to know she just
appeared in the middle he has like some
kind of weird hiding place in this [ __ ]
and i don't really know
where it could be you might be going
underneath the couch
can she fit under the couch no maybe if
she like flattens herself outside maybe
i guess so the one time we have all
those kind of things that are up on the
wall you know like all those little
hey pokey we were just talking about you
she's like i know that's why that's why
i came
and that's like you know there's all
these little things they can jump on
like little shelves and whatnot and then
there's this little thing that's kind of
like
what would you call it's like a little
capsule kinda yeah and it has a hole in
the top and they can get in there
and you can't see them because they can
like hide in there now a couple times
when she when we couldn't find her we
found her in there but today we didn't
find her because if you knock on it like
her little head will pop
up yeah just pepper says cats can fit
under anything
she might be able to fit under the couch
i mean
she probably could i would imagine you
haven't seen sandra saget sandra hasn't
showed up
haven't seen t either we have to start
without them
we're gonna have to start without them
yeah
i guess says fudge is cool tom cruise
loves fudge yeah haven't seen sophie
their soap's probably hanging out with
their boyfriend
yeah i hope so yeah that's that's right
david where's
teal and sophie i don't know yeah so we
were just i don't know i'm just talking
about that
well you know it's friday night yeah so
not everybody's gonna be able to like
[ __ ]
hang out talk about serial killers like
we do on friday night
ask me how the beer is i don't drink
beer well very rarely
not yet very rarely yeah we're not real
we're not real big beer drinkers pretty
much the only time we drink beer is like
if we're at a place that does have a
liquor
license yeah
and then i'll get like a coffee ale or
vanilla stout or something like that but
i don't
really like almost i like this [ __ ]
what's she looking at her look
what's she doing yeah
she's in the bed you guys i have my bag
that i'm going to take because i start
packing it tomorrow so it's all empty i
think all it's in there is an umbrella
and i just turned around and booked he's
like sitting in the street popping up to
the top of it like hey
okay got bored with that
oh my god okay yeah i was gonna tell you
i saw mr mcguire today too
yeah he's been you know what he does now
he's he jumps up on the bench and sits
next to me
so he'll just sit there next to me on
the bus it looks like he's like on the
bus on the bench it looks like he's
waiting for a bus that's what i was
gonna say
so it looks like we're both sitting
there waiting for a bus him in the
[ __ ] waiting for you to show up well
yeah yeah
every time i walk up he's like
because i bring him food i guess he says
tila might still be working
yeah maybe not working super chad super
chat
contour video caught your video on the
texas killing fields this week new sub
well hey
welcome super chad all right mango i'm
seeing them bro
are you guys sending boob pictures again
back and forth i'm not gonna show
well yeah that's not cool is that both
her it looks like it's
in context of boobs that sounds like a
really funny thing
are those both her boobs or is that one
boob next to another boob don't show
them like other people's oh
oh okay i got you yeah
okay all right yeah
oh [ __ ] uh serial killer in cat chat
that's what this is pookie is going on
vacation she's not though she's staying
here
but she was trying to go on vacation
she's like mommy i want to go with you
in the bag
i'll have to sneak her into the airbnb
what are you doing i don't think pets
are allowed
[Laughter]
oh my god victor says i'm off friday to
sunday now so i'll be watching this show
off the clock
yeah oh god damn kitty she's like
pay attention to me yeah we uh i
we recorded like a bunch of shows for
next week
and i've already uploaded a bunch of
them and
so you should be able to see them at
about the same times as you would
normally see them
you know what i mean like and if you're
a patron you'll be able to see them
early and all that other kind of stuff
i think i i will have to take my uh
laptop with me and i but i think the
only thing i'll have to do is like just
click the
the videos over to public on youtube
like on the day and then
upload the uh file for the audio version
of the podcast but that won't take very
long and all i have to do that like once
a day
so i was going to take my laptop with me
anyway
uh camp guy says there is a cat cafe in
my town
there is one in st augustine too and i
wrote it down because i definitely want
to go there
it's you might have to like make an
appointment but maybe not they said you
don't have to but
you can go in this um you can go in the
little cat lounge
and you get like it's like 10 bucks and
you go in there for an hour and you can
have like cocktails and hang out with
all the kitties and stuff
it looks adorable from the pictures i
can't remember what it's called
whisker something or other i don't know
but it looks really cool i might have i
might try to do that
that was one of the places that i wrote
down that i wanted to see
uh why am i coughing uh
britney says watch the tusk movie review
and sixth sense now i need to rewatch
both
yeah sexual problems actually i was
watching uh
um was it what's it called unbreakable
yeah i watched it unbreakable
and uh i got a breakable have glass i
don't have shatter did it show up
split or split excuse me yeah i call it
every time yeah you do
[Laughter]
it's not in yet it might be here today
yeah did you check the mail
yeah i checked the mailbox it wasn't in
there oh okay that's something that they
would deliver to the door
all right maybe i'll get it tomorrow
yeah i was supposed to get that other
shirt today too but i guess it didn't
show up unless it showed i consider i
can check
they don't ring the doorbell enough and
they just leave [ __ ]
they just leave [ __ ] on the porch that
was so funny i can't believe she jumped
in that [ __ ] bag
my cat will jump into any vehicle in our
driveway if you leave the door open she
travels well
yeah i don't i don't know i thought
about because tom's like why did jake
pookie with you and i was just kind of
like yeah no it's like the airbnb i got
like they
don't allow pets and i'm like that would
probably just stress her out
this is her house and she loves it here
so if i had to take her somewhere else
she'd probably freak like the couple
times that i we had to put her in a cat
carrier like take her to the bed or get
fixed or whatever
she was wigging out the whole time she
was up there yelling
or pokey oh man there's nothing up there
nothing up there okay
yeah victor says remember when that lady
pitched her cat cafe idea on shark tank
like 10 years ago and everyone thought
she was nuts i hope she's a millionaire
now
yeah there's the cat cafes everywhere
it's a great idea
but as long as you keep the place clean
i don't think you'd want a dog cafe
because that's kind of like they'd
probably poop
everywhere but the japanese have one
with uh raccoons
oh no see that'd be neat too yeah
somebody
yesterday was talking about how mean uh
raccoons are they're not that mean
well i guess it depends on the raccoon
depends on raccoon um
but uh beijing's better been out on the
back porch just
and like three of them just ran up and
she said hey how you doing
and cats love raccoons you think that
there'd be some kind of
conflict but no cats love raccoons and
raccoons like them
there's lots of videos of raccoons and
cats domestic cats just hanging out
you just don't want to grab a raccoon
you probably get hurt
well that's kind of true of any animal
yeah i'd have them i've had them hiss at
me before
i jumped into a dumpster one time that
was empty but the raccoon couldn't get
out
you know yeah so i jumped in there to
get the raccoon out
and put a box a cardboard box in the
corner and chased him into the box and
shut it and then
handed it out to the guys that were
outside and then let the raccoon out
yeah that's him that was the way to do
it but he was hissing you know but
you're scared well yeah he was probably
just trying to train yeah he wasn't mean
they'll run yeah thank you no need for
me to tom and jenny look like uh
nicholas cage is the color out of space
yeah we always kind of look like that
all those pretty lights in the
background oh there's the mountain yeah
[Music]
i know i really i really like the way
this but i have this room like this all
the time whether we're recording or not
you know what i mean yeah
see that's what i thought tammy says
maybe cats think raccoons are just
funny-looking cats
i think that yeah i think they do i mean
for sure beijing is just kind of like
ooh look at that pretty kitty
yeah beijing it was it was love
she started like following she's
following him around
[Laughter]
we don't see him all that often but like
i said i think i've mentioned this
before but there used to be a little
family of raccoons that lived in the
parking lot where i worked
because there was a girl that would give
her give them pizza crusts
because she didn't eat pizza crust so
she would like put them in a bag and
then she would bring them out for the
raccoons
so the raccoons had just every time they
saw somebody coming at them with a
plastic bag they put their little hands
out like hey pizza crusts yay
all right uh somebody just saw a tic tac
ufo all right
[Laughter]
yeah see i think the cat cafes i don't
think the animals are behind
plexiglass or anything like that i think
they're just wandering around yeah they
walk around
they're just wandering around yeah like
i said i'm gonna try and go to the one
in saint augustine because it looks
super cute
but uh we'll see because like i said
i love the kitties i love the kitties
i don't know i'm not i'm not casting
aspersions on that why couldn't there be
a dog cafe i'm sure the dog cafe too
i'm just saying dogs are a little harder
to that it'd be a little harder to keep
clean
you know what i mean yeah because dogs
will just kind of poop anywhere
cats usually they gotta poop in a
specific place
and they're not as stinky cats aren't as
stinky as dogs
at least in my experience
uh okay so are we ready to like start
talking about [ __ ] serial killers now
yeah go for it
uh mr rabata says jen you could always
say your cat's an emotional support
animal
on the airplane yeah i i could do that
she is an emotional support animal all
right so
are you like distracted by boobs or what
no no okay
just wait and wait for it he's just over
there like checking out of the show
okay yeah also cats don't bark
good point cats bring us presents
because they think we're dumb kittens
that don't know how to hunt
that's true and if you're beijing you
bring us all stuffed animals
and then cry over them because she's
super weird
all right so let's talk about this
[ __ ] and like i said
it just it blows my mind that this dude
isn't better known because
as i said he killed well they know he
killed
the five people in gainesville they
think allegedly he killed three other
people in shreveport louisiana
and the way he killed them was like
super super
grisly it was like super brutal you know
mutilations rape
everything and he's just really not as
well known as ted bundy and i'm really
not sure why that is
because there's not a lot of difference
he's that same type of dude
do you know what i mean not as maybe not
as
because you know how ted bundy had that
kind of fake
charm thing and you know he had like a
job and a girlfriend and [ __ ] like that
danny rowling not so much he was more of
like
a drifter type of guy but he you could
tell he
he looks catchy from the photos i've
seen yeah
i mean he didn't look like a bum but in
custody in the photos that i saw so i
don't know he looked like he's walking
around but
no [ __ ] bundy bundy was the [ __ ]
hugh hefner of serial killers
yeah it doesn't get any better in terms
of physicality and
charm i guess so you can't get any
better than that don't expect much of
these dudes
you're grading them on a curve that's
very very true
most of them [ __ ] losers
well they have to be other why would
they be doing this why would they be
doing this [ __ ] if they weren't
so as i mentioned uh mango says never
heard of this guy looking forward to
finding out more if that sounds right
yeah
so this guy all right so this happened
back in 1990 like i said now i had just
graduated high school
in you know may or june of 1990 and
several of my friends were going to the
university of florida which is in
gainesville
now see that's another way that it's
like ted bundy because ted bundy killed
some people
at florida state which is in tallahassee
but this one happened at university of
florida so i knew like a bunch of people
that were going there
now this happened in like late august so
a lot of the students had gone to the
campus
and were just like moving into their
apartments but classes hadn't started
yet
you know what i mean so it was that kind
of situation
so it's four o'clock in the afternoon
uh sunday august 26 1990.
so the police officer ray barber
uh it's the end of his shift he's about
to go home
and then he gets a call on his radio
now at first they don't think anything
about it the call was just
a noise complaint like somebody is
blasting music from their apartment
really loud
so he's like well you know obviously
like all the college students just got
here
they're setting up their apartments
everybody's partying because classes are
going to start blah blah
so nobody thinks anything about it so
he's on his way there then he gets
another
message and this message was also not
all that weird
it was uh just a regular just assist
citizen assist or whatever um so he's
like okay well i'm on my way home but
i'll stop and check it out
and i would probably regret that for the
rest of his [ __ ] life i'd imagine
the call had come from williamsburg
village apartments now
he gets there and he the maintenance man
was the guy that he called him like the
apartment
manager like the maintenance guy so
the maintenance man says this girl
this girl's parents are here uh you know
this student that lives in this
apartment building the parents are here
because
they um want me to open her apartment up
because they've been calling her for the
last couple of days and she hasn't been
answering her phone
and they're really really worried about
it and he's like well
i didn't know if something was wrong and
i didn't want to get in trouble
so i thought i'd call you guys to open
the apartment because i don't want to
take responsibility for opening the
apartment if there's something wrong in
there
now the police officer at first uh isn't
worried he's just kind of like oh you
know teenagers they do that kind of [ __ ]
all the time you know they don't they
forget to call their parents they do
this and the other thing and then
they're totally fine
um but the problem was the
uh parents whose name were frank and
patricia powell
uh they said you know our daughter whose
name was christina
she was 17 years old um they're like she
knew that we were driving
over today like from jacksonville and
when we asked around nobody had seen her
since
friday morning and it is now sunday
afternoon like late afternoon
uh so they became very concerned
um and then they said well we also
asked around and it turns out that her
roommate
whose name was sonia larson who was also
17 years old
uh also had not been heard from for
a day or two like and her mom had
already like
become worried and like started to
complain because she was supposed to
call and she didn't
so at this point uh they call in
uh a bunch of backup because they think
probably something's uh
the matter and then the media turns up
they go into the apartment
and find not surprisingly these two
17-year-old girls have been horribly
horribly murdered uh
one of them has been raped and
they're both pretty much left it looked
like
i think what he did was he attacked them
when he was when they were sleeping
you know what i mean he either came in
like through an unlocked door or he
would like pry
the door open like with a crowbar or
like a screwdriver or something
and then he would attack him while they
were sleeping one of the girls had been
raped and it looked as though he had
tried to kind of
clean up uh like this is gross but like
he tried to like clean out
like semen and stuff like that because
between the legs of one of the victims
they found like a bottle of
dishwashing liquid yeah you know what i
mean so i guess he
tried to like [ __ ] i don't know what
the [ __ ] he was trying well it's obvious
yeah it's that's what i mean it's just
kind of like [ __ ] that's disgusting
trying to uh decontaminate the uh yeah
the area there so to evade
identification
yeah uh guys have done it before uh
law enforcement have done it uh
receiving the law enforcement have found
guys to try to do that before bleach
yeah yeah
shoot bleach inside there and then all
over
and in one case that i heard about dude
did that
to her and it had spilled all over
and she survived he didn't know it but
she was awake or she was alive
and it burnt her up and god damn it
unfortunately it was like it was a
really good looking
little black girl you know who's
probably 16 or 17
and the scars on her skin it showed up
you know what i mean it basically
she had patches of pink and white white
you know
all over you could see where all the
[ __ ] it was nasty
you know what i mean felt really bad for
her she was on a
like a a program about that offender
and she was just scarred up all over she
couldn't [ __ ] with guys anymore or
anything like that
well [ __ ] can you blame her yeah and he
had ported inside her
god so there's no telling you know what
it did to her in the inside [ __ ]
terrible
yeah i mean he was a serial he was a
serial he was a serial rapist
but he but i don't remember if he killed
anybody but he thought he killed her
but she wasn't she was alive she woke up
uh a long time later she'd been
unconscious because he'd beat her so
badly can you imagine
he beat her into a coma if i remember
correctly they didn't really find her
you know until six seven hours later and
that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] bleach had just eaten her
up
chemical burns yeah yeah i mean [ __ ]
like this man it's just [ __ ] horrible
and like i said in this case in
particular this is exactly and
and yes this type of serial killing is
very rare
where someone just random [ __ ]
breaks into your apartment with a
[ __ ] screwdriver while you're
sleeping and then
starts raping and stabbing you um but
i mean it does happen and the fact like
i said and i remember when this happened
because i just graduated high school
it was the summer after i knew a bunch
of people that had gone there
and it was all over the [ __ ] news
you know what i mean because like i said
i'm from central florida and a lot of
people here knew
you know people that went to school
there because that's kind of the main
that's the main big college in central
florida
so i mean it was like all over the
[ __ ] news it was like a huge deal
so yeah so they basically they kept a
lot of the
real like nasty [ __ ] away from the media
to start with but they basically came
out and they said yeah like um
two young women the two women were
murdered uh somebody
forced their way into their apartment
sometime between 11 30 p.m
august 23rd and 4 p.m august 26th
because like i said they had been seen
a few days before but that was the last
time they're in there reacting to that
bleach story yeah it's bad
it's been a long time that was early 90s
i think when i when i heard that one
that was like something that was off a
geraldo or something or maybe it was
america's most wanted it's been a long
time
but uh yeah it was [ __ ] nasty she was
actually kind of a good girl
and the dude that did it was from the
hood and she was like what you would
call a day like
what you'd call like a black barbie she
was like really pretty
black check he targeted her because of
that
she was only like 18 or 19 he just
[ __ ] ruined her life man [ __ ]
terrible
it hadn't been on a white girl it would
have been bad too but the scars wouldn't
have showed up as much it was just that
dark black skin with those big
patches of [ __ ] white scar tissue all
over it's [ __ ]
real sad yeah that's [ __ ] horrifying
yeah proper pov says has there ever been
a serial killer who was killed by a
victim
somebody mentioned yeah the candyman
that's dean coral
i don't know well it wasn't really a
that wasn't a victim that was like
yeah it was a teenager that he that was
like an accomplice
yeah but it went too far he was going to
kill a girl
and and yeah the accomplishment now
[ __ ] us you guys and the accomplice
killed that
was killed but the accomplice was like a
teenage kid
yeah and he did a bunch of time because
he was selling those teenage boys to him
yeah and in a way i think a modern court
wouldn't have done that to him he was
under the influence of an older dude who
was [ __ ] terrified
that d he didn't have a choice the
accomplice it was that's kind of what
i'm leaving so i mean you know yeah
it was all [ __ ] up but yeah i mean he
was groomed from a pretty young age
yeah so i'm not excusing what he did
obviously
he didn't deserve that he should have
gone to an institution that had helped
him out and [ __ ] trying to de-program
him he wasn't an evil person per se he
was just
brainwashed yeah and uh
and he did take the [ __ ] out
yeah that's gonna account for something
yeah
dean carl started [ __ ] getting ready
to torture a girl which he normally
didn't he was homosexually normally
tortured boys and uh it compass clicked
and [ __ ]
grabbed [ __ ] dean's 22 revolver and
shot him right through the head
which took him out and then [ __ ] then
the story came out he let let the
victims go
yeah um but no they gave that guy yeah
he was
he was an accomplice but he was he was
under under duress i mean
the same thing could happen to a woman
there were a lot of women who were
partners to these serial killers they
didn't have a choice
yeah it's like what else are you going
to do you need to kill them yeah you're
just going to get
the same thing with that guy and he'd
sucked him into it to where he didn't he
couldn't back out he felt the guilt
because he'd been involved in it from an
early age you know
yeah so it's not it wasn't quite the
same thing you know
that's right as an adult getting
involved in it
yeah um all right so
basically like i said now at this stage
uh the cops they don't obviously they
don't know it's a serial killer yet
because this is the first uh one that's
happened
it's a double homicide uh they kept a
lot of the details from the media they
basically just said you know it's two
young girls they were murdered
um but and they wouldn't even say who
they were at first
but i guess that some people that lived
in the apartment
complex and some people around like knew
who they were so you know the
the rumors started going around uh they
said that both of the girls were
freshmen they had just arrived obviously
because they were 17
so they had just graduated high school
the previous the previous spring
they said one was from palm beach
florida and the other one was from
jacksonville although no one knew them
very well because they had just
arrived now the cops asked
uh we're asking around to see if anybody
had heard anything
unusual um and all that the p
the neighbors could think of they said
well we heard somebody showering in
there
and they heard somebody playing music
really loud like on friday morning
uh it was george michael if you wanted
to know
um and then he said he heard like a lot
of loud banging on the walls but
he just presumed that oh well the girls
had just moved in so they were just like
hanging pictures or moving furniture or
whatever so he didn't think anything
about it
now this is [ __ ] scary too so like so
this is how like all the cops are still
there it's still a [ __ ] crime scene
[ __ ] like that
and then this other girl like
walks up to the building uh she had been
out of town right so she walks up to the
building because she lives in this
building
and she goes to the door and one of the
cops like uh you know pulls her aside
and she's like you know who are you and
she says my name is elsa strep
and it turns out she was their other
roommate
right and so they told her they said hey
both your roommates have been like
brutally murdered
and she was just like i mean can you
imagine what that would be like like
just to come home like hey i was like
i was away all weekend yeah that's
probably like what she thought but holy
[ __ ]
oh my god i can't imagine just like
coming up and like seeing a bunch of
cops there
like yeah both your roommates are dead
and weren't you glad you weren't home
it's like that's really [ __ ] up
really [ __ ] up so
all right basically uh so they're doing
like their regular
cop [ __ ] um even though the cops had
kept the worst of the mutilations
uh out of the media and away from the
public
uh rumors still started going around
anyway uh that the
um that at least one of the victims they
like i said they're one of them had been
raped i think christina powell was the
one that was raped
um and i'm pretty sure that there had
been some
breast mutilation uh which
would make sense because there was that
on some of the later ones as well
uh so you know so those kind of rumors
were kind of going around and everyone
was
understandably kind of freaking out
now as if this [ __ ] wasn't horrible
enough
they were just kind of they were still
like uh
at this at the williamsburg apartments
and still kind of like packing up all
the this crime scene
and then they get called to another
crime scene now this
ended up happening because i guess like
barbara the officer before like his wife
was also
uh an officer and her name was gail
barber
and she said okay so there was this
woman
this young woman and her name was uh
krista hoyt
and she was 18 and she worked the late
shift
um as a records clerk at the alachua
county sheriff's off
sheriff's office and gamble barber the
cop
she was like we got really worried
because
krista hoyt didn't show up for work
and we kept trying to call her and
there's no answer
on her phone now as i said
at this stage yes there's a double
homicide
but no one's thinking serial killer yet
they just think maybe it's some random
you know maybe it's somebody that knew
him or some [ __ ] like that
so no one's thinking these two things
are connected not yet anyway
so gail is kind of like okay well we're
kind of worried about it we've been
calling krista no one's answering the
phone
um so they sent a couple officers so she
and another officer went over there
to krista's apartment and knocked on the
door
and they're like oh well maybe she left
for work already it wasn't that late it
was only like half hour after the start
of her shift or whatever
so they're like okay it's probably fine
but then they turn around
and they saw her car was still in the
parking lot
so at this point they start knocking
again to try on the door
the door is locked the apartment manager
comes
out and the apartment manager and the
two cops
go around to the back of the apartment
building
now immediately the apartment manager
knows that something is the matter
because the chain link fence around the
back of the property
looks like somebody has stepped on the
top of it like while they were climbing
over
and like the gate was kind of [ __ ] up
so it looked like somebody had tried to
bust in and it wasn't like that earlier
so basically the cops are like okay well
[ __ ] this is not looking too good so
they send the apartment manager around
to the front
um no one's in the yards they tried the
sliding glass door
uh which was also locked but then one of
the cops
noticed that the there were some kind of
like venetian blinds or like bamboo
shades over the um
over the door the sliding glass door and
they didn't go all the way down
so one of the officers
bends down and puts the flashlight like
underneath
like looking into the apartment at which
point
they see um what appears to be a naked
woman
sitting on the edge of the bed
bent over at the waist and there was a
little
um pool of blood at the feet
the feet still had shoes and socks on
them but the rest of the body was naked
now while they went like this and kind
of scrolled up
this naked body that was sitting on the
end of the bed
didn't have a head damn
can you imagine looking into i'm it's
like i know you're a cop and you see
horrible [ __ ] all the time
but even head wasn't at the scene yeah
it was it wasn't the scene
okay this is what i was talking about
when i was talking about like ted bondi
yeah ted would have taken it though
well yeah um so at this point
they're like holy [ __ ] [ __ ] because
like i said i've seen i watched a bunch
of documentaries about this and a lot of
the cops were just kind of like
we had never seen anything like this
before i mean gainesville is like a
pretty safe
and ironically i was reading something
that ironically in 1990 when these
crimes happened
uh money magazine named gainesville
florida the 13th best place to live in
the united states
yeah that's something i wanted to just
mention real quick
i lived in florida for how long more
than 10 years now huh yeah
10 11 12 years or something i've been
i've been all over the world this place
is [ __ ]
calm and safe especially for a place
that's well depends where you are
just like everyone let me finish it's
calm and safe
especially for a place that is in the
south and it's built up
built up like this and it's made up of
people that come from all over the
united states and
in the world miami was kind of like
one of the main point of entries for the
drug trade it's built on a [ __ ]
it's built on [ __ ] uh the skyline was
built on a sea of cocaine
going back to the miami vice era
but still it was relatively safe there
it still kind of is you do have
a couple of neighborhoods that you don't
really want to
[ __ ] around with too much but even
compared to say like sao paulo brazil or
colombia it's still nothing
so [ __ ] like this even though you hear
these floor-to-man stories
one of the reasons why florida man
stories happen is
you hear about them because they stand
out they're [ __ ] weird
you do have some weird [ __ ]
here you do
well because we kind of get everybody
all the weirdos from everywhere
kind of congregate down here because the
weather is nice yeah
well it's hot it doesn't it it's but we
don't have a strong
winter all right very tropical
the whole serial killer thing and these
kind of mean-spirited
crimes if that's where you want to put
them are unusual for this culture
compared to some of the other places
this is more like some place that you
crimes like this is usually what you
find like in a dying city
something up in the rust belt doesn't it
seems like or someplace where
uh like out in l.a back in the 60s or
the 70s where like the porn scene was
attracting a lot of prostitution and
then
scumbags [ __ ] show up for the
prostitutes and then
they're from somewhere else but they
show up to this scene and then they
start killing people it
it's it's weird to to live in here to
associate
weird [ __ ] like this with florida
florida in general is a happy place
it's wild though yeah you got gun fights
that doesn't mean that it's not happy
here
those dudes are in the drug trade
shooting at each other
sometimes they kill each other they're
having a good time
that's how they're looking at it you
know what i mean i guess so they well
yeah they're fighting over drug turf or
whatever
but that involves guys that are in crime
i don't really feel sorry for them
that's between them yeah
not at all you don't have too much of
that i mean especially where we live is
like super chill i'm just like
i'm never like worried around here ever
no it's like pretty
yeah yeah suburban yeah you know what i
mean well even you go downtown orlando
i mean downtown is a little sketchy but
it's like i used to go down there by
myself all the time and it's just kind
of like like i said every now and then
you'd get kind of in a sketchy situation
but
i never thought i was gonna die or
anything it's nothing compared to la
or detroit or sao paulo brazil or uh
it's nothing
compared to new orleans new orleans is
real rough especially certain areas
nothing compared to even jackson
mississippi jacksonville
some bad [ __ ] having jackson if you go
to the wrong place
even though that's a small city it has a
high crime
rate certain areas it's just
the vibe of florida is in general
positive
it feels like a resort era area which
that's what it is
yeah that's true like i said a lot of
stuff is kind of new construction
they try to make everything look like
disney world jenny was basically born
and raised in this area
she's been oh she's in daytona she's
been around you know
but she hasn't lived for long periods of
time in real [ __ ] holes you know what i
mean like i lived for
almost two years in detroit second in
west hancock
down there in downtown detroit that's
like the [ __ ] combat zone all right
i lived in real [ __ ] holes before this
before i was in the army
there's nothing like that nothing
that's where i got my first [ __ ]
pistol it's in detroit that was underage
i bought a cz-75 a tap illegal cz-75
off a drug dealer for 50 bucks and it
didn't work but i fixed it
yeah but he said hey man you want a gun
said dude don't [ __ ] [ __ ] no no no
no he showed it to me but this is this
is a collapsing [ __ ] city
he says is it stolen he goes i don't
know there's somebody else
we're just passing the ball yeah yeah
i'm just trying to make some money
for it you get 200 a student i have that
how much you got i only got 50.
okay all right
fifty dollars worth of credit to 50
bucks it is crack whatever yeah
he needs entertainment for that evening
yeah 50 would probably buy a lot of
crack i mean
i don't know it was a nice pistol it
didn't work though yeah no
didn't work you're missing the main
spring that's no big deal
e4 mafia says it's so hot in florida
yeah yeah too many straight roads
it is very straight here it's very
grid-like not so much where we are
because ours is kind of curvy but
because ours is kind of like country and
[ __ ] i don't think i
i don't like i never like disliked
florida because
it was rough or anything like that i
didn't like it because one
it's hotter than [ __ ] satan's [ __ ]
and i can't stand it
and two it's just like a lot of where i
grew up was like real rednecky
yeah you know what i mean like real like
white trashy rednecky kind of [ __ ]
and it's like i don't really like all
that rednecky kind of [ __ ] yeah c4 mafia
that is the new snake plison shirt
this is the larger size version of
and uh if you drop me a 20 super chat
i'll send you one
just after the show jenny will get your
uh syngenia message we'll get your
address i'll send it out to you we
we got to produce shirts tomorrow so
i'll i'll shoot it tomorrow and send it
out tomorrow
yeah just let me know like you're having
a couple days mailing address and size
all that kind of stuff
uh all right so where was i okay so like
i said
after the cops saw this horrifying
[ __ ] thing that's just like it seems
like a [ __ ] horror movie man
like looking underneath the [ __ ]
blinds and it's like there's a
there's a person sitting there and i
haven't seen the the
crime scene photographs i'm sure you can
probably find them because it's the
internet
but i did see a documentary that had a
little like uh
you know cartoon or computer like
reenactments of how that what
yeah you can send paypal instead yeah
that's that's fine that's fine
um what else was it somebody said
detroit has improved nico said that yeah
i still got friends in detroit
um detroit improved because they tore
most of it down so that's a coffee out
there
yeah go ahead yeah so can you imagine
like looking into a [ __ ] apartment
and seeing
a naked body like sitting on the end of
the bed and then realizing that
it doesn't have a head i mean i just
can't even imagine what that's gonna be
like so what's the paypal email um
oh hold on [ __ ] just hold on let me type
it
she's putting it down she's typing it in
the car in the comment section
okay don't everybody don't spam me yeah
don't spam me
i mean i don't care if you spam me i'll
just [ __ ] okay hopefully that doesn't
yeah and in the notes if you send us the
money
you can probably send the notes to the
paypal right yeah yeah when you send
pages
put your uh address in the note just
mailing address and which shirt you want
with size and what yeah
what size you want well you wanted a
piskin one right yeah but just put that
in there
large clip skin and then the size of the
shirt
yeah because otherwise i can't keep
track and like i said we're making sure
it's tomorrow
yeah and mailing them out so all right
so
where was i okay so at this point the
cops are like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] and they run back to
the patrol car
to call it in so at this point it's one
in the morning like i said
you know earlier they found you know the
first two bodies and now they found
another one
so it's uh been a day as they say
now one of the cops says um i think i
hear water running
in the apartment so for a second they
thought maybe the killer would like
still be in there
so they basically they had to like take
up positions all the way around the
apartment and then they had to wait for
more backup like before they could go in
so it was like half an hour
what i have to answer question just how
do you take the head off without getting
blood everywhere well there was blood
there was like a
there was like a puddle underneath
though yeah if if it's post-mortem the
heart isn't beating so when you [ __ ]
cut the head off it
it won't gush out a whole lot but if you
have ever cleaned an animal
like a deer done you field dressing
there's not a lot of blood
now maybe she might have been awake or
alive when he cut her throat
this possibility i mean his mo was just
like to stab the [ __ ] out of you
okay well then there you go and uh the
the head was cut off post-mortem
post-mortem
yes uh they did know that good
so you cut a deer head head off and it
won't be a drop of blood
yeah yeah so like but there was blood on
the floor the cop saw it
might have been from stabbing her though
yeah because like i said he uh he did uh
stab the [ __ ] out of everybody
okay so uh so yeah where was i okay so
they said that they heard water running
in the apartment and they thought the
killer was still in there so they called
for backup
and so they actually didn't go into the
apartment until half an hour after they
had first seen
the body so they come in through the
front door
they checked in the bathroom they could
hear the shower like water dripping in
the shower
but there was nobody in there now there
were blood stains on the floor of the
shower
which means probably that the killer uh
you know took a shower before he left um
so when they came out of the bathroom
they found uh christa's head
it turned out that what this
[ __ ] had done
was he had cut her head off and then
pulled around a bookshelf and then put
her head on top of it
so that it was looking at her body
because that's a thing that you do
apparently and like i said that's some
ted bundy [ __ ]
and i think he did some [ __ ]
necrophilia and show like that too but
i'm not entirely sure about that because
i've seen different reports about
about that but yeah so they found her
head and it was looking
at her body like he moved the bookshelf
specifically
so he could put the head on top of it um
and also this is also fun
on the bed next to her they found her
nipples
okay which he had cut off and put
next to what the [ __ ] man jesus christ
the [ __ ] the matter with you i mean
he's dead now so
he's dead now but yeah so uh
they uh checked the rest of the
apartment and uh determined that the
killer
is no longer in there
now at this point uh
they're pretty sure they have like the
the cops that were at the williamsburg
village apartments
scene and they were they twigged on
pretty quick that
you know this i don't know if the
murders happened the same day exactly
but they found them the same day like
only a few hours apart
and so they were pretty quick to say you
know this [ __ ]
is probably linked because they were
very very brutal there were mutilations
they were both stabbed with what looked
like the same kind of knife
somebody mentioned the kind of knife
what was earlier would it what's it
called like k bar or something like that
yeah it was a like a hunting knife yeah
and the combat knife
uh from marine marine combat yeah yeah
yeah
so yeah that's what that's what this is
yeah and also another uh fun thing is
that
when they um so they you know do
they check out the apartment make sure
like the dude's not there make sure they
get all the clues and everything
and then they go to move the body
this poor [ __ ] headless girl
and uh not only had her nipples been cut
off
but the killer had also
made a big slice like from her
breastbone to the pubic bone so he had
like
cut her open what you can finish the
sentence you don't have to just say what
um e4 mafia says keep that extra twenty
dollars
that he said oh thank you thank you very
much appreciate it thank you very much
tomorrow and send them out yeah we got
to go to the mail
yeah somebody was asking how do you
order like i said you can
drop a 20 super chat tell us what shirt
you want
and what size we'll write it down and
then send jenny a private message with
your
um mailing address on it and so we know
who it is
and just make sure you resubmit the
order so we know who you are so we keep
all that traffic
all that straight tomorrow we'll we'll
print i'll print up shirts
yeah i'll do it together that's what
we're gonna do you'll have in a couple
days
hopefully unless you're overseas unless
you're overseas yep
yeah so this has somebody asked about
the saddle store
the zazzle store has totally different
designs
i didn't make them they tend not to last
as long they come off in the washer
well they're digital printers although i
have some that that it stayed
for a really long time i don't know why
yours faded so quickly yeah just because
i have a whole bunch of them and they
like they look just as good depends on
what it is i guess and what the decision
is or maybe yours get washed more often
than mine i don't know maybe
because i have more t-shirts than you so
the ones we make
the ones we make by hand are made by
hand
and it's that image will not come off of
there
it won't and um i use some of the best
[ __ ] dyes
and uh if you if it if the shirt itself
ever fades
you can re-dye it with rit and it will
not stain the the
the white on there i got some
paramilitary stuff coming to probably a
green shirt or a gray shirt
with like cross rifles and it'll say
stuff from the show and this shirt that
you get also comes with a label on the
back
make sure they can see that jenny it
says 13 o'clock
on the back so it's got two images
so it's got two images on it actually
yeah okay
all right yeah so what was i saying so
yeah she was sliced open
from the breastbone to the pubic bone so
at this point like i said they're pretty
sure
because not only you know there's not a
ton of murders in gainesville and
you know definitely not any that are
this brutal
so they uh you know we're pretty quick
to figure out that these three murders
were uh definitely connected uh and
you know aside from just the brutality
of the crimes there were also
other little things that were also the
same uh both scenes whoops i just
knocked a box over
both scenes um some of the girls
underwear had been
stolen um same knife like i said that uh
combat knife four to six inch blade had
been used on all three girls
and uh it appeared that the girls had
been
tied up with duct tape which had been
removed and taken away probably because
the killer knew that
duct tape is really good at holding
fingerprints
and so he didn't want to leave it behind
so after they were dead
he probably ripped the tape off and then
took it with him
you know what i mean yeah
i mean answering questions victor said i
had the show on jenny mode i paused it
for a phone call and forgot it had been
paused so i was like 20
minutes behind yeah yeah definitely
that's how that's how it should happen
he's asking me something about it about
a testosterone update he's been gone for
a few weeks i've not
asked him to clarify but i don't really
know what he's talking about
just been uh going into end of
month three been good i went down
dropped from like probably 30 [ __ ]
body fat down to maybe like 20
20 something when i hit 15 percent body
fat you'll [ __ ]
it'll it'll look real good do that i
want trying to trying to get between
that 10
15 body fat region um
put on muscle [ __ ] losing fat
metabolism works
you do cardio you lose weight fast if
you diet you lose weight
uh if you work out you gain muscle it's
just like you were 15 or 16.
yeah that's just instant response okay
good
instant response instant response dj
maniac says
did last podcast on the left just do a
series on rolling oh they might have
um i forgot to look uh i forgot to look
for them
i just because i guess i haven't watched
any of their stuff or listen to their
stuff in a long time
because usually if i you know when i do
a search for a serial killer if they did
one on them it's usually theirs as one
of the first ones to come up
but it didn't come up but i'm sure they
have because they've done one on [ __ ]
everybody
like but i now have to look and i should
have really listened to it before
because they usually do a really good
like two or three part
uh breakdowns of like all this serial
killer [ __ ] and they're funny as hell so
that helps too
um hold on yeah uh
dc and i know what i know now
here at 42 go on knowing what i know now
have gone on at 40.
you'll love it yeah brittany said yes
last podcast on the left just did it
theirs is pretty good too they just did
it that's crazy
i didn't yeah i didn't know i didn't see
it i've been like i said i've been
putting danny rolling up in the
poll like the patreon poll for like i
put him up i think two or three other
times and he just never won
and it just happened that he won this
week so that was what
but like i said now i'm gonna have to go
listen to that because i really like
live last podcast on the left
yeah britney goes i was surprised when i
came back after a week how much of a
difference i saw on tom
as a female i'm talking my husband and
going on just testosterone
yeah [ __ ] i don't know how old he is
but knowing what i know now like i said
i'd have gone on at 40
and i wouldn't have had to [ __ ]
struggle so much during my weight
lifting and training routines
and uh hitting that hormone crash
if you're [ __ ] late 40s early 50s
[ __ ] you up
um downside of it you know you ask jenny
[ __ ]
i pester her i [ __ ] i do i passed her
just like you can't get off her [ __ ]
boobs i'm trying to [ __ ] all the time
she gets mad and i'm going like no come
on you know she said
it's just you know it well it's like
sometimes i have like dude i have to
take out the garbage or i have to like
juice i have to do something you know
what i mean
the thing is that you can't predict the
[ __ ]
it's just it just hits you the [ __ ]
moon beam hits her the right way it
bounces off the ass the right way it
spreads a [ __ ] rainbow jumping off
the back
or off the [ __ ] and then i'm just gonna
go there i'm gonna hit this
and this and you don't really want to be
stopped
and you and she has to shake you back to
your [ __ ] senses but
you can't go back to your senses you're
like 15.
and i do 200 milligrams a week
i broke it up into two and two
injections over 100 milligrams each
every three and a half days i i shoot
myself up with it
and that keeps that peak i'm probably
trying to prevent that big
peak i like to little i'll try to keep
it kind of
level um
i did the research lately it is hormone
replacement therapy
but no teenager could ever have
what i have running through my veins
consistently 24 7.
because it's it's exogenous it's coming
from outside the body
most guys only make tests when they're
asleep
and right before they wake up that's why
they wake up rocked up
if you're not rocking up if you're not
waking up rocked up you're [ __ ] wrong
something wrong with you
your test is low well
i have that almost all the time almost
so it's very easy to lose weight
it ends up being kind of like
you're always sleeping you're always
healing even though you're awake
you make [ __ ] a high level of
testosterone even if you've been
drinking
even if you're smoking it doesn't matter
it's in there so you're not dependent on
internal manufacture it's coming from
outside
which solves most of the problems
everything rebuilds you get stronger
you're more aggressive you're more
likely to get yourself in trouble
you really gotta [ __ ] watch it
especially if you're drinking
um yeah cause you gotta like get in a
fight or something yeah yeah i go
i go to the club and i'm going like i'm
gonna beat that fucker's ass and she's
like you can't do that i said yes i can
it's a very much i'm like no you you
really can't
start are you going to go to jail
i could have beat the dude's ass that's
what i mean i was like so i had to like
start a whole fight with him because i'm
like what are you doing what are you
talking about you can't do that did you
get through now you're gonna get
arrested
yeah you're like 52 and you're getting
ready to just tear a [ __ ] 25 year old
up
like yeah we'll [ __ ] stomp him into a
greasy spot and i'm just like
and then she's trying to talk me back
into it it's not it's not really worth
it and i'm going like
that i'm gonna get this young buck in
line i'm gonna [ __ ] him up you know
because
they can't really compete with you they
don't have the same body mass their
little bitty arms and
you just go like i could crush him i'm
gonna crutch him
you know but you're going to get in
trouble it's not really worth it
yeah that's not good yeah no it's good
it's good it's just you're going to pay
for it that's the it's very good
it's very good it's just you don't want
to pay for it see that's the thing
if you can get away with it then it's
understandable but you wouldn't i
wouldn't have gone away when it didn't
call the cops on me
well yeah and then that cost and you had
to spend money to get bonded out or bail
out
and then you got to go to court and
everything so it ends up costing
mourinho's worth
you don't really have to make a point
like that it's when i'm sober it's not
well that's what i was trying to tell
you
right now i'm sober it's not a problem
it's just but you were getting all like
you're drunk you're getting all freaked
out about it when you're drunk your
inhibitions are gone and there's really
nothing to stop
you and you're like this guy's a bug i'm
gonna [ __ ] squash him
you know and i'm gonna show everybody my
dominance
that's exactly what you're thinking you
know he's lower rank than me i'm gonna
twist his head off
you know it's just [ __ ] like that you
know so you gotta
and then i'm just over here going yeah
[Laughter]
but not like i'm too old for this [ __ ]
yeah not all guys are gonna react that
way
too old for this [ __ ] yeah it's just you
start going like i'm mine
it's a different it's like a bloodlust
in a certain way but
no it's not that strong you can fight it
off
you can fight it off dudes are so
special yes
yeah but you're going to be hot and you
know what kind of special i mean
you're going to be hot all the time
you're going to sleep beautifully
you sleep beautifully you wake up real
rested
um very very mentally positive
like yeah yeah yeah i can do it um
good energy level had i known everything
that i know now about it i would have
started at 40.
now is it dangerous no and yes
if you do what i'm doing now if you
started at 18 or 19 exogenous you're
going to [ __ ] yourself up
you want to do it towards the the last
half of your life
and you don't want to have been at
abusing any kind of damn anabolics or
anything like that or any kind of drugs
before so you want your livers and
kidneys to be in good condition
you don't want to be obese by the time
you hit 40 something
speaking of warm it's good it's kind of
getting warm i guess because i'm like
drinking that's like right when i drink
it
if you're healthy at 40 or 50 that's the
time to go on
because it was cold in here earlier yeah
and uh
it may extend life there are some guys
that have done it
um done it with anabolic steroids
instead of testosterone because they
didn't have it
and at right therapeutic levels like
jack lalanne
they died old in their in their 80s i
think late 80s
and they they were strong and in good
health when they died they died of other
things you're going to die anyway
you look at it this way i will trade
what's happening now will trade this for
the extra five years or
if it cost me five or two years or six
years off the back end of my life i
don't care
because you're gonna be an old man
watching television those past five
years anyway it's not gonna [ __ ]
matter well the thing is
you don't do anything you wouldn't know
anything no you wouldn't know
you don't know i mean you're just gonna
die when you're gonna die you wanna know
if i had done this other thing i would
have lived that you won't know any
different so
don't worry about it it should extend
life just based on keeping your weight
down
and the stress off your heart and it's
good for your heart at the doses of trt
level it's good for your heart
now you start [ __ ] five times what
i'm doing and
steroids and [ __ ] no to [ __ ] your heart
valves up that's why those guys died
young but
now what i'm doing is nothing compared
to what a bodybuilder does nothing
just pepper said jenny i felt that sigh
all the way from arkansas
yeah yeah yeah you feel me you you feel
me you know
you know what i'm getting at uh chaz is
asking do you give sandra london a pass
for her behavior
i do want to get into that a little bit
um
no not really i think she's also i don't
you know obviously she's not
akin to danny [ __ ] rolling but i
think she's kind of like
a parasite and she kind of uh
i don't know it's kind of like i was
watching uh dr grande he's this
psychiatrist
and he kind of psychoanalyzes like all
of these serial killers and other
celebrities and [ __ ] like that too uh
and he's really funny because he has
like this really
he's just like so meticulous and he just
talks and he sometimes he'll make jokes
but he makes the jokes in the same exact
tone of voice
and it's just that really really makes
me laugh because he's like has this just
very very dry sense of humor but he was
saying
he said a little bit about her and he
said well he's like yeah
maybe danny rowling was using her maybe
she was using him
but you know maybe they were using each
other i just kind of feel like
she was just using that to make money
like to write a book
you know what i mean yeah they're in
there saying got um
a gay male and a straight female
brittany uh saying that she they both
want to use tests
um yeah if you if you're having problems
losing weight you got you you can go on
test
like i said if you're around 40. it'll
come off a lot easier but
go to the gym and lift all right you
don't have to lift to get giant but
that'll help
walk maybe do some cardio brittany yes a
woman can do it
uh you can find the dosages and uh
there's some other things
supplements along with it usually
fertility drugs
that you can get go to an hrt clinic
and uh yeah you'll get ripped you'll
lose a lot of weight but like i said you
gotta have
eat high protein look low carbs do some
resistance training it'll come off you
and yeah it it it's worth the trade off
if
for the risk there there may be some
risk
long term but probably not as risky as
being fat
long term that what fat obesity kills
people
easy [ __ ] your cholesterol up your
[ __ ]
clog your arteries a lot of stress on
your heart so yeah just keep it help you
keep weight off and you look great and
yeah
test will make you uh even a woman it'll
it'll make you a [ __ ] monster
so be prepared
be prepared what chance the boy scouts
always say what test does to a woman is
slightly different than what it does to
a man it's a much smaller dose
they're taking much less but it does a
slightly different thing for a female
you can look into it hold on but it will
cause you to lose lots of weight and
gain lots of muscle
but you can control that
okay so let me get back to the case okay
so at this point uh right so there have
been three murders now
double murder and a single murder and
clearly both committed by the same
person and they've been horribly
horribly brutal
even though the cops were trying to keep
the worst
details away from the media um
a lot of them kind of got out anyway and
actually one of the cops
i think he even said to the media um
after
krista's murder um about the beheading
and about that kind of stuff so that
actually did get into the papers
and not surprisingly everybody in
gainesville was
freaking the [ __ ] out because at this
point they knew
that it was just this maniac that was
running around killing people at random
which is like stabbing them and stuff
because they pointed out too that not
only
did the victims not know each other but
they didn't even go to the same
school like christina and sonia the
first two were um
they went to uf lee university of
florida but krista
went to santa fe community college so it
wasn't like he was just like targeting
you know students from that one school
or anything like that it could just be
kind of like anybody
so at this point kind of everybody you
know they get all the [ __ ]
you know florida department of law
enforcement fbi ever they get the
[ __ ] behavioral specialists all that
kind of [ __ ]
so they have a press conference monday
night which i guess was about 24 hours
after they found the first
bodies and uh i really don't i didn't
envy their task
because they pretty much had to come out
and tell the public hey there's nothing
to worry about even though clearly there
was something to [ __ ] worry about
because
there was a lunatic running around like
stabbing people uh so you know
so uh that that is definitely something
that should be worried about
and at this point and this is something
that i remember uh
specifically uh after the third
murder um a bunch of students
like the phone lines in gainesville got
all jammed up because all the students
were trying to call home being like
should i come home should we leave like
and you know parents were calling to
make sure they were okay
parents were going to gainesville to
pick them up i remember
one of my friend's moms well then i was
like talking her and she's like i think
i'm gonna drive up there and get her i'm
gonna drive there and get her and they
were doing a you know
people were freaking out and a lot of
people left and they didn't come back uh
because
classes haven't started yet you know and
uh they i think they actually pushed the
start of classes back a week
uh because of this um or you know pushed
it back a little while
uh because a lot of people did leave uh
and didn't want to come back
so you know basically
they so so everybody in town they start
doing like
you know the [ __ ] that you would do uh
if you thought a serial killer was
running around
they had like all these people nobody
would stay in apartments by themselves
everybody had like you know [ __ ] a
dozen of their closest friends
everybody's staying in the apartment
uh you know nobody walks anywhere by
themselves in the daytime or the night
time or anything
um and everybody was just kind of like
mistrustful of everybody because they
didn't know who the [ __ ] this
[ __ ] was
is it another student uh i think that
was kind of the first thing that they
presumed because
you know because the three victims were
college students so they thought maybe
this is another student
uh so you know you couldn't really trust
anybody
so it was that whole kind of uh [ __ ] too
then the next day august 28th which was
a tuesday
they found two more bodies
this time uh one of them was a guy there
was a guy and a woman
happy oh my god pokey
so these two victims were tracy paula's
and manny tabota they were 23 years old
um they were actually friends and
roommates
and they lived at gatorwood apartments
uh i guess manny had had a previous
roommate and then that
roommate moved out so he had this friend
tracy and she moved into the other
bedroom now the scary thing about this
was that manny was a big dude i mean he
was like
i've seen some six foot one some six
foot three but he was like a big i think
he was like a football player something
like that he was an
athlete anyway he was like a big like
200 pounds big muscular dude
um and he was murdered just uh
just the same and uh which is kind of
sad because i think that
tracy's parents maybe weren't as worried
she's like oh she lives with that big
dude it's like nothing will happen to
her
but guess what uh apparently what
happened was the killer
broke into the apartment and stabbed
manny first while he was sleeping
like attacked him while he was sleeping
and just started stabbing the [ __ ] out
of him he should leave poop once go
outside okay
outside yeah she's going front door
front door
and um yeah and there were a lot of like
defensive winds like on his arms and
stuff so obviously he had been sleeping
the killer jumped on him and started
stabbing the [ __ ] at him with his
hunting knife
and the guy had fought him but uh had
not
won that fight unfortunately because uh
he died
now i guess what ended up happening
in this situation so seven o'clock
tuesday morning
uh manny had a friend named tommy
carroll
and he i guess came by the gatorwood
apartments
because um somebody had asked him to
check in on manny and tracy because like
i said everyone was kind of freaking out
about like the serial killer running
around
and this mutual friend of theirs hadn't
heard from either one of them for a
little while um
so it's like no one's answering the
phone so
they get the manager they you know have
uh they send the maintenance man to go
like check it out
so the maintenance man comes uses master
key to open the door
now this is [ __ ] crazy the
maintenance man
opens the door to the apartment with the
key right
and as soon as he opens the door he saw
tracy dead and she was naked she was
laying in the hall
like between the two bedrooms like with
her legs kind of spread out all bloody
and everything like that
and there was um like right by her head
there was like a bat like a dark bag
like a
you know like a bag you'd carry [ __ ] in
you know like a bowling bag or whatever
and so the maintenance man sees this and
it's like holy [ __ ]
and closes the door now he comes back
five minutes later with the cops like he
closed the door and locked it
because he had the key he comes back
five minutes later with the cops five
minutes later the door was unlocked
and the black bag he had seen earlier
was gone which means
that when the maintenance man opened the
apartment door the killer was still in
there
which is why tracy this is why they
presumed that tracy was not
as mutilated as the others because
apparently the killer had been
interrupted by him
opening the door and seeing the body but
he deliberately you know they're
thinking he deliberately left the body
there
so that you would see her like with her
legs spread out like as soon as you
opened the front door
because that was kind of his thing he
liked to like even in the first case
you know the first two girls um he
he wanted to pose them for like maximum
shock value
he wanted like as soon as you walked in
he wanted you to see them
you know naked in like a real degraded
uh you know kind of pose he was real
into doing that kind of [ __ ]
so so this was apparently i don't know
what he had planned to do with this
victim but
apparently he was still in the apartment
when the maintenance man opened the door
and he was gonna do something worse like
to her dead body but he didn't get a
chance to do it
presumably so he had been still in there
but i guess he got away
so at this point um you know they
like i said manny had been killed uh
first they thought you know
obviously because he was asleep and so i
guess
i don't know if i don't know if danny
rowling ever
said that he targeted certain people
specifically he did have a type because
it seemed like
all of his female victims were had like
dark hair
that was kind of long and dark eyes and
they all kind of looked similar
um so i don't know if he knew
necessarily that there was also a guy
living in that apartment
um i would presume that he probably did
know because he seemed to have gone
right into
the dude's room and killed him while he
was sleeping before he got started on
tracy
so maybe he had been like watching them
for a while i'm not entirely sure
but you know uh okay so at this point
this is the fourth and fifth
victims so at this point like i said the
story pretty much goes
uh national and uh the media started to
point out all the similarities between
this case and the ted bundy case
which like i said ted bundy also killed
uh a bunch of people in well he killed a
bunch of people everywhere but he killed
a bunch of people in florida
uh at uh florida state university in
tallahassee
and uh this he's similar kind of thing
he would cut off people's heads and
pose them or take them and do that kind
of [ __ ] like he's doing the same kind of
[ __ ]
uh and interestingly i think ted bundy i
think had just been executed
like a year before these murders right
because i think he was executed in 89
if i'm remembering correctly um i knew
it i know it wasn't very long like from
when ted bundy was executed to when
the danny rowling uh gainesville ripper
murders happened
so yeah so this is like all over the
[ __ ] news like i said
so the cops are getting all these leads
um
you know so they're looking into any of
these girls
ex-husbands ex-boyfriends people like
people who worked around there everybody
anybody that was acting any little bit
weird
um was gonna be looked into
now at this point uh there's one name
that keeps coming up like a couple
people have reported him
and the cops start looking at this dude
uh
pretty seriously and as
you know as they look into his
background it's like obviously
this is gonna be the prime suspect
at this moment spoiler alert this is not
who it was but
i'm not gonna give the cops too much
[ __ ] because i can totally see
how this would have happened although i
still feel kind of bad for the guy
but he didn't really help his case
either
you know what i'm saying it's like so i
can totally understand why the cops
maybe thought it was him
so this dude's name was edward humphrey
now i guess there was a cop that lived
either in the same build like in the
same building as him
and i think that this cop like brought
this dude to the attention
of her superiors um
and when she did it they're like yeah
we've had a couple other calls about
that guy
because the thing about him one uh
edward humphrey lived
in gatorwood apartments which was the
same complex uh that tracy and manny
lived in you know the fourth and fifth
victims
um and there were also a lot of reports
about him being real weird or real
violent
they said that um he was very strange
like he'd been kicked out of his house
by his roommates
he was a sleepwalker the maintenance man
and the apartment manager had
asked him to leave the property and he
had become violent and thrown things at
them
and he had also lived in the apartment
complex across the street
from the gatorwood apartments and he had
gotten in trouble over there as well
like he would walk into people's
apartments like without being invited he
would like look in people's windows
he would do that kind of [ __ ] so
everyone kind of knew that he was a
weirdo like around there
now in early august like about
three four weeks before the murders took
place he was arrested in colorado
for disorderly conduct and then they
took
his uh car and they kept him in custody
for 24 hours
now his grandmother whose name was elna
hellovati
lavati uh she came and got him and
brought him back to gainesville and
helped him find an apartment ring
so there was another thing too where it
seemed like according to many reports he
was very violent toward his grandmother
as well um and you know there were other
things that
uh he had harassed people there were
reports of that
uh the fights um he pulled a knife at a
frat party one time when they tried to
stop him from coming in because he
wasn't invited
it was that kind of [ __ ] so uh
he pretty much becomes their prime
suspect like i said they found it very
suspicious that he lived in the same
building as two of the murder victims
and had this long rap sheet of
violent and strange behavior so like i
said i can see
where they were coming from with that i
mean he did look like a good suspect at
the time
and i have to say too this is
unfortunate
but if you see pictures of him he had
been in a car accident
um at some point in the past and so he
had
kind of scar his face was all kind of
scarred up
so i think that maybe didn't help you
know what i'm saying
because i think like him looking like
all scarred and weird looking
i think people are like oh yeah that's
totally a serial killer
and the thing about it too is i i
remember this happening too because i
remember
them like the news and [ __ ] like putting
pictures of this guy in like newspapers
and everything and he
the pictures of this dude were like
splashed all over the media
with those like oh prime suspect prime
suspect which he kind of was
i mean he was a good suspect but they
had a bunch of other suspects too
but the media only showed pictures of
this guy and named this guy
um and i remember i think i even
remember thinking back then oh they got
him
you know what i mean because they made
it seem like that's who it was
and like i said he was violent he did
get arrested for that kind of [ __ ]
but he wasn't a killer you know what i'm
saying so it's kind of like a shame
that that kind of uh happened that way
because he didn't
you know he wasn't a great person but he
didn't [ __ ] deserve that did he
so they start uh following him around
and uh you know they got helicopters
following him everywhere
and um so october 30th
which was two months i guess after the
murders
the cops actually had an opportunity to
arrest him because it turned out that he
got into a fight with his grandmother
and he hit her now his mom
called the cops uh and the mom got the
grandmother
to sign a complaint for aggravated
assault
now i think the grandmother didn't want
to press charges
but the cops were like well we're
totally pressing charges because we
think this guy might be the gainesville
ripper so we want to keep him in custody
um so that's kind of what they did i
mean he did do something bad allegedly
so they did have reason it wasn't like
they were keeping him for no reason
but you know they wanted to keep him as
long as possible
as possible so they arrest him on an
aggravated assault charge
and he gets arrested taken to a regional
medical center
uh and then the fbi came
and started interrogating him and he
gets questioned for
24 hours without a lawyer present which
that's that's that's not good um the
public defender came
and uh the public defender got uh sent
away
which again not good so this guy
like i said not a great guy but uh not
not kosher like the way they treated him
really
so uh basically what the fbi
said to the public defender was like
well
we haven't arrested him for the
gainesville killings this is for another
you know case he got arrested for
aggravated assault so you don't need to
be here
uh you know so and we couldn't say oh we
arrest him for the gainesville ripper
case because there wasn't any evidence
because
spoiler alert he didn't do it so he's
there on the assault charges
and they like i said the grandmother
dropped the charges but they kept him
anyway because the cops said we're gonna
press charges
so he gets sent to brevard county jail
um and they set his bail at a million
dollars
which is uh a little excessive
for a minor assault charge uh and this
was also his uh first
offense so he's waiting for his trial
what
a refill yeah okay
so he's waiting for his trial uh which
was set for
uh october now as i mentioned the mug
shot of him with the scars all over his
face and stuff like that
uh thank you no need for me to
chat check out the song by tom's
tombstone every mile bay
i'm pretty sure it's about this k oh it
might be it might be
um yeah so they basically printed
pictures of this d
of this poor dude um all over and like i
said i
i remember that happening and i remember
thinking oh they caught the gainesville
ripper you know what i mean and everyone
was kind of like glad about it
so i was like oh that's got to be him
because that's the way they made it
sound
they made it sound like it was him so
you know uh you know it yes it's the
media's fault they were like oh prime
suspect prime suspect but the cops
didn't really do anything to dissuade
the media from saying that
um they didn't give out any other names
to the media they didn't give any other
pictures to the media
so it was kind of like this guy is it
and that's all there is to it
so at this point so they don't have any
evidence as i mentioned
linking him to the gainesville killings
and because there was no evidence it
took the cops
four days to talk a judge into getting a
warrant
to search uh his apartment his car
uh they also wanted to search his
grandmother's
house because i guess he stayed there
sometimes like when he was between
apartments or whatever
so finally after four days they get the
warrant
and then they comb through his car and
his apartment
uh and the grandmother's house and they
didn't
really find anything um you know they
found
some screwdrivers but they couldn't
match them too because
uh a screwdriver had been used to like
get into a couple of the apartments
but the screwdrivers you know didn't
seem to match any of the [ __ ] that they
you know any of the entry marks or
anything like that so they go to the
grandmother's house
um and i guess the grandmother wasn't
home
when the cops got there and i wasn't
aware of this but i guess if they have a
warrant they can just
you know they just busted right in um
you know
it was no one was there super chat
yeah i know i already said i'm i'm way
heavy
um yeah so they call locksmith they go
into the house
uh and this old lady gets home and finds
the cops uh ransacking her house
she has a moment uh and passes out they
had to call an ambulance
so even though at this point they've
gone through his
his apartment his grandmother's house
his car
um and haven't found anything that would
link him to
the murders but he's still the prime
suspect
because that was i guess that was kind
of all they had and like i said he was
kind of a little bit of a weirdo and he
did have some like
history of minor violence and like
acting like a weirdo
um it also didn't help that after he got
arrested
the murder stopped so that was another
thing
that made them think that that dude was
just oh they got somebody i'm going to
stop doing it
well i still yeah that's what he's
probably well no that's not why
so because um
everybody just kind of assumed that
edward humphrey
was the guy and they had caught him so
everybody started to kind of chill out
oh they got the serial killer so the
students that had left started coming
back
and everybody kind of was like whoo
that's over
um you know and [ __ ] went kind of went
back to normal
they said like even on the for you know
because the story was obviously front
page news
in all the central florida newspapers
for you know a really long time
um but then after a while everyone just
kind of not forgot about it but
we're just kind of like oh it's over now
because they thought that they had
caught him
um you know so like i said this is
really like unfortunate
so october edward humphrey gets sent to
trial on the assault
charges uh his grandmother testified his
trial
and went back on her thing and said no
he didn't hit me
um because like i said she had dropped
the charges prior
despite that though edward got sent uh
sentenced to 22 months at chattahoochee
which is a state uh mental hospital
so there you go uh and it's it's for the
criminally insane
is what it is they actually made a movie
a while back with gary oldman in it
called chattahoochee that's about that
place it's kind of infamous
look she's trying to open a damn closet
door you can't open that pookie you're
too little
there's nothing in there that's
different than usual have fun
she takes the beats out there's not
outside that's what
[ __ ] doesn't go out she's like this is
[ __ ]
that got ripped open a door and go out
she keeps forgetting she keeps
forgetting
yeah so so they sent him to
chattahoochee for 22 months
and he doesn't get released until
september 18th of 1991
uh yeah so they put him in a [ __ ]
essentially like a a home for the
criminally insane
and he didn't really do anything other
than maybe smack his grandma which like
i said don't do that
but not really like raping killing and
murdering
and mutilating five people i mean you
know it's kind of kind of not same
so the sad thing about it is that i feel
like
he was still considered a suspect up
until the point
when danny rowling finally got sentenced
and that was until 1994
and i don't think that edward humphrey
ever got any compensation or
even an apology or anything it was like
hey sorry we splashed your [ __ ] name
all over the media and said you were the
gainesville ripper
are bad and they just i
i don't remember if this is true because
it's i don't know if it's in my notes
but
maybe i heard it on another documentary
but i think
that his grandma was like so freaked out
that she like had a [ __ ] heart attack
or something like that she might have
like more than one
i don't know if she died but you know uh
so while so it turns out that while the
cops were doing the surveillance on
edward humphrey who
it turns out was not the gainesville
ripper
turns out the real dude who was the
gainesville ripper
danny uh rolling he had actually
just gotten uh away with
a bank robbery so here's what was going
on
so danny rowling who again spoiler alert
is
the gainesville ripper he had actually
um been hanging out this was august 28th
which was two days after the fourth and
fifth murders
so he's been hanging out with this guy
named tony danzi
not tony danza tony danzi
so they're hanging out in the woods uh
they have a campsite in there
and uh this was near where christa hoyt
had been murdered
like uh near her apartment building now
in this campsite
um i guess danny rowling had made this
campsite there like uh
the afternoon before like the the first
murders had taken place like before he
did them
so i guess he'd been hanging out with
tony danzi because
tony was a drug dealer and i guess danny
wanted some drugs so they started
hanging out together
now the cops actually noticed them not
because he thought they were murderers
but just because they thought they
looked sketchy or they were like up to
something sketchy
so the cops started like you know being
like hey what are you doing
now tony stopped to talk to the cops but
danny
ran off which again very suspicious
at this point like i said the cops don't
think this has anything to do with the
murders or nothing they just think that
these are two sketchy guys walking down
the street and they want to know what
they're up to because like i said there
was drugs it was
[ __ ] like that so uh so danny rowling
runs off
into the woods and the cops uh chase him
and they end up finding his campsite
they didn't find him but they found his
campsite
now they found a bunch of stuff at the
campsite
that would later be important in tying
him to the murders
but at that point they didn't make the
association between those two things
because they didn't realize that this
was the guy
um however they did see that at the
campsite there was a bag full of cash
that had
pink dye on it and they're like hey this
is the dude that just did the [ __ ]
bank robbery
and that's who we were looking for uh
this was a
the first union national bank uh that
had been robbed on the 27th or the 28th
uh and this was you know the guy they
were looking for obviously because here
was the money
um but because the cops had not uh
associated this bank robbery with the
murders
they took all his [ __ ] from the thank
you nico
thank you nico cat 86 cheers and happy
friday
same to ya
you know because the campsite was there
so they took all his [ __ ] and they just
kind of like
stored it as they would because it's
like crime scene but they didn't really
like look into it any deeper than that
because they just thought he was a bank
robber
now at this point i guess tony and danny
rowling
uh you know met up the next day and tony
said
hey i'm gonna call the cops on you um
so danny kind of took off and he didn't
have any money
because obviously they had taken all his
[ __ ] from the campsite and he didn't
have a car either
so he figured well i better steal some
[ __ ]
so he breaks into an apartment of
another student named christopher
osborne who i don't think was home at
the time
but while he was in there he stole the
keys to christopher's car which was a
1978 buick regal
and he started driving toward tampa
now while he was uh on the way there
he broke into another bunch of houses
like looking for [ __ ] money and whatnot
um but he didn't really find much of
anything that was going to help him on
his uh
absconding um but he did leave
a bunch of uh clues behind like hair and
fingerprints and [ __ ] like that
now he was robbing a convenience store
at one point and he almost got caught
but then he ran into the woods and got
away
uh but his uh escape wouldn't last much
longer than that
so danny steals another car and starts
driving to
ocala which is where my mom lives
it's a big place though but it's it's a
big like national forest but there's
like towns and [ __ ] in there too and a
lot of lovely springs
just gotta say it's right in the middle
of the state my mom was there
so he goes to ocala in ocala
he decides he's going to rob a
winn-dixie
grocery store in the middle of the
afternoon
on a saturday this was september 8th
1990.
so he walks in there uh big swinging
dick
he forces the manager at gunpoint to
empty the safe
in the office now i guess what happened
was that
somebody else that worked at the store
like the bookkeeper or something she was
coming back from like her lunch break or
whatever
and she somebody told her like at the
entrance hey
some [ __ ] is in here like you
know robbing the safe or whatever and
she's like well [ __ ] i'm gonna go call
the [ __ ] cops
that's what she did so she went and
called the cops so the cops already got
there
by the time uh danny was leaving the
grocery store and like heading back to
his getaway car
and also the store manager hero uh
followed the dude as he ran out of the
shopping center and he knew what
the getaway car looked like so when the
cops came he's like there he is right
there officer go [ __ ] get him
so danny rolling backs out of the
parking uh
parking lot and uh the cops start
chasing him there was a high speed chase
and then danny crashed the car and then
ran
uh you know started running way on foot
uh he runs into like an office building
like kind of runs it's like hey whatever
and then he runs out through the rear
door
but obviously the cops like you know
they they knew he was going to do that
so they kind of like
headed him off at the pass uh so he like
tried to escape
but he didn't and he finally got
arrested
so was there anything else you you
needed to say no i was looking at how
long that took you and i was like
boy i made good time when i shut the
[ __ ] up well yeah
see i'm talking to people inside the
chat room and keeping everything all
orderly and answer answering questions
and [ __ ]
okay yeah all right how long how long's
the show been running
uh um and only an hour and 43. okay
good all right yeah i mean like if we
finish early we can just talk about
other [ __ ] that's fine it'll be okay
yeah you were only halfway through yeah
chad says he's making dumb moves like he
wanted to get caught maybe you know
maybe he did because i just feel like
he's a serial killer for sure but i feel
like he had this weird thing where
it's almost kind of like he did a bunch
of minor crimes
and robberies and stuff like throughout
his life but then
just all of a sudden he decides i'm
gonna kill like a whole bunch of
[ __ ] just like in
a couple of day period which is really
strange you know what i mean
although i guess like i don't know i
guess ted bundy kind of did that kind of
[ __ ] too
so they arrested uh danny rowling
on september 11th 1990. um
so basically so what happens
is that i guess at this point
danny rowling is in jail for
the grocery store robbery i don't think
at this point that they had associated
the two things like i said because at
this point edward
uh humphrey was still
in custody like on the assault charges
and he was still like prime suspect
danny rowling was just wanted for the
bank robbery
and the the other uh robbery the grocery
store robbery
um because he had done a bunch of
burglaries like convenience stores and
[ __ ] like that
and he was uh they were looking at him
for that not so much for the murders
now once when they arrested danny
rowling he seemed like pretty chill like
yeah you got me
um and he just cooperated with the
police and the cops and everything like
that
um and they said okay he seemed like
pretty chill
but then he was in custody for a few
months
and then in early january of 1991 um
he seemed to have like a fit of violent
rage like somebody like made him really
mad
and he ripped a toilet like out of the
ground and
like threw it across the room you know
what i mean
so and nobody had really seen that like
seen him behave like that
prior like you know in in the jail or
whatever
so at this point um his defense attorney
is like yeah um
let's get some psychological tests on
this guy because
he seemed like pretty chill and
cooperative when he came in here but
ripping a toilet out of the floor and
throwing across the room
that's you know that's maybe something
we need to look into
so uh so they had some psychological
tests uh
done on them and um i guess that
danny rowling had pleaded guilty to the
armed robbery charges
and the defense attorney said that she
said that they should withdraw that
because maybe he had some psychological
problems
now at this point what ends up happening
is that because the gainesville ripper
murders the five
students that were killed uh the
brutality of them
everything like that and because the
story had gone national
uh police in louisiana uh because
you know they had that what's that
called that vicap or whatever like where
you put
you know it's like the nationwide
database of like crimes and if you put
in
like hey all the weird details of the
case like it'll it'll ping if like stuff
in other parts of the country have the
same specific weird details
so i guess what happened with that was
the cops in louisiana
they called the authorities in florida
and they said hey
um we have an unsolved triple murder in
shreveport
louisiana that happened back in november
of 1989
and some of the details of it are real
real similar to those [ __ ]
gainesville ripper
cases that you've been working on um
what hap what happened in that case it
was a it was a family and this is like
really horrible
so the ones in shreveport where it was a
55 year old man named william grissom
and he had a daughter named julie who
was 24
and she had a son who was eight named
shawn
and i guess these this little family had
been in their house
and they were getting ready to sit down
to dinner and
some [ __ ] just broke in and
brutally murdered them all
and julie the 24 year old was also raped
and her body was mutilated in much the
same way
that many of the gainesville victims
bodies were mutilated
uh was cleaned in the same way i'm
presuming with the dishwashing liquid
kind of deal like uh like some of the
other crimes
so they thought this was very
interesting uh so at this point like one
of the investigators
from florida goes to shreveport to kind
of look into the similarities
there were other similarities too uh the
victims had been
posed like in a really degrading way
like for maximum shock value
there was also duct tape residue on the
bodies
uh vinegar had been used to clean them
and uh
they said they did they tested the body
fluids from uh the killer in shreveport
and said the person had a b
type blood so like i said at this point
i don't think they were real sure that
danny rowling was their guy because they
were still kind of focused on edward
humphrey
but this was just you know shreveport
cops
saying hey these murders were very much
so you might want to look into it as
probably like the same person
now after the florida investigator went
to shreveport that was november of 1990
there was another woman uh who was lived
in shreveport her name was
cindy jurassic jurassic jurassic
something like that she actually ended
up calling the crime stoppers hotline
and reported that danny rowling was
probably connected to both
murders she said that she had been
in the florida panhandle three months
earlier in august of 1990 when the
murders were occurring
and that um she had heard about the
murders on the news and it made her
think of
the [ __ ] that had happened in shreveport
and she said
me and my husband knew danny rowling
like not he was like kind of an
acquaintance or whatever
and she told the police she's like danny
rowling said some really weird [ __ ] to
us
um you know a few times like he was a
real weird dude
and he used to come over their house
sometimes and
she's like um at one point my husband
was like yeah we can't hang out with
that dude anymore because he's like
there's something to matter with him
like he's got a problem and she said
that her husband said
because she was like what what is his
problem and then
the husband said he likes to stick
knives into people
um so at this point she's like i wasn't
really sure because we kind of knew this
guy and i didn't really think that
he had done that horrible triple murder
in shreveport but she was like but then
when i was in florida and i heard about
the [ __ ] in florida
she's like i thought maybe so so i
thought i would like call it in
so that was another thing that kind of
uh you know put him on the radar like
for the cops like i said for the murders
anyway
so as i said he had been arrested for
the supermarket robbery and he
was uh you know in the in custody i
think the
supermarket robbery was uh the
winn-dixie was ten days
after the fourth and fifth murders uh
tracy and manny
and uh that was only it was only 40
miles away from gainesville
uh so they did a blood test and they
found out that danny rowling indeed had
type
b blood just like the suspect in both
the gainesville and the shreveport
murders so at this point
uh they figured okay well we need to go
back
into the evidence locker and look at all
the [ __ ] that we took from his
campsite on the day of the bank robbery
when they weren't
thinking that he was a murderer they
just thought that he was a robber
and they took all his stuff and just
like stuck in an evidence locker
somewhere
so they take all of the stuff out of the
evidence locker and guess what they
found
they found a gun they found a
screwdriver that matched
the uh the scrape wounds on some of the
oh there he goes that's right i gotta
cool off on
straight ready right now he's going i
gotta have the head decoration
yes i've had the head decoration i'm
gonna you know what that's fuzz right
here i'm gonna
i'm gonna get you you know how like they
have uh when you have like a little
babies a little babies are bald yeah and
then they have like those little
little a little bonnet or like a little
hairband or they have those little
barrettes
yeah for little girl babies or boys
whatever that have like little um
what do you call it like velcro yeah so
you can just like stick them on top of
their heads like
they don't have any hair too much yeah
it's too much too much look there's too
much white
ones that you need some little more you
need some little barrettes
yeah so i gotta have i'm gonna put some
or a little flowered sun hat gotta put
something that's gonna you're making
this [ __ ] go all blurry i gotta have
style on it
xanada says you need a head tattoo nah
come on man
a kid would come up with some [ __ ] like
that he's like [ __ ] 20. come on why
don't you like tack you like a brain
and like a cracked open skull with a
brain that'd be neat no
just put [ __ ] hats and like a little
goggles and [ __ ] man they're [ __ ]
going great
going riddick on these [ __ ]
they see that i just do that and see
that looks good too
okay i look like i look like somebody
mad max fury road
eyes on eyes on eyes on remember yeah
eyes on yeah you're gonna paint yourself
white
yeah yeah put a little black or kind of
you kind of look like a bee also
yeah like a bee
[Laughter]
yeah okay so they go in the [ __ ]
evidence locker
they find a gun they find a screwdriver
that matched
the tool marks at a couple of the sites
they found a cassette player that had a
cassette tape in it
where danny was
he sang some like songs i guess that he
um
had written because he was a songwriter
too because of course he was
and he oops that must be a delivery that
might be something
doorbell ring are you gonna come with me
she's like no i'm too lazy um but yeah
it's r you can hear it it's on youtube
and it's
they played it in some of the um
documentaries and stuff
but he's basically it's it sounds like
he's talking to his family like hey
don't worry about
me and then like the last thing he says
on the tape he's like and this was
before the murders like right before the
murders
he says something like well you know
gotta go don't worry about me i've got
some things to do
he says on this [ __ ] tape so they
found this [ __ ] tape at the [ __ ]
it's probably that t-shirt yeah it feels
like something like that
yeah it is that's that uh one special
order oh and i had the black t-shirt
yeah yeah i just needed to get that i
thought it was coming today i just
thought it was kind of late
uh but yeah so this [ __ ] tape is
super [ __ ] creepy the the fact that
he says that's the last thing he says
i've got some things to do and then
obviously that's
was the things he was going to do he had
to go [ __ ] cut some people up because
[ __ ] jesus christ
all right um yeah
jesus christ all right so yeah so this
audio diary like i said
uh you know had a bunch of stuff that
was real incriminating sounding
now at first it seemed like danny was
pretty cool with
uh admitting guilt like for all the
robberies but he wouldn't really
say that he had done the murders however
he didn't seem all that shy
about telling uh other inmates about it
and he just like [ __ ] blabbed his
[ __ ] head off about it
so what happened it was weird because a
lot of the people that he talked to like
in prison that you know that
uh went to the authorities later they
said that it was almost kind of like
sometimes he seemed like he felt really
bad about it but then sometimes he was
just like yeah i did that [ __ ] and he
was like bragging you know what i mean
this dude was like so [ __ ] weird
i get he's one of those dudes that i
can't really
i can't really get a handle on you know
what i mean he doesn't like
his personality doesn't seem as
developed
as i know it's a weird thing to say but
it doesn't seem as developed as maybe
some of the other serial killers that
you like
immediately like you hear them talk or
whatever and you're like oh this
person's this that and the other
this guy just seems really looking
naughty like in non-entity that's
exactly what i was gonna say
real generic i think it's because when
they did all the psychological uh
evaluations of him
pretty much all of them said that he had
the emotional age of a 15 year old
boy like he wasn't real you know what i
mean
he wasn't stupid but they said he was
his
iq was slightly above average but
he just i don't know he seemed like he
was kind of
i don't know what his deal was some
dudes just won't talk
he's probably one of those it's like he
did but then the shitty said i don't
know i couldn't i could never determine
if he was ever being genuine or if he
was like taking the piss
or i don't know it was like really hard
to tell he's like a weird dude he was a
weird dude
so he makes friends with this other
inmate
named bobby lewis um who fun fact was
the only man to have escaped from
florida's death row i'm not really sure
what the story behind that is but i just
saw that in my notes so at this point
danny's like okay well
maybe um if bobby escaped maybe i can
also escape
uh he's like so because he's like even
if i don't get convicted the gains feel
[ __ ] he's like i'm probably still gonna
be in prison for the rest of my life for
all the [ __ ] armed robberies that i
did
so i guess because
he thought that bobby could help him to
escape
so he basically told bobby everything
like all the murders like
down to the tiniest little detail right
so he tells him all this [ __ ]
hold on one second i see a lot of
people's comments are vanishing
i think if you cuss in the comment
section i think the ai immediately takes
it away
so that's why your comments are
vanishing
which is weird because i don't have that
yeah it's just youtube does what it
wants
it cuss or if you say something that it
thinks is hateful
it's not gonna just because of the
wording i mean the ai is not good
all right it'll just take it away so
just be careful what you say
reword it either that or
like maybe they build something wrong
and took it away yes
uh but yeah so um
yeah so he told bobby that
he said well when i was in prison before
because i guess he'd be in prison before
for something else back in the 80s
uh that he decided back then that he was
going to kill all these people
before he even came to gainesville so it
wasn't like you know
that was like just something he randomly
decided um
now at this point he tells uh kind of a
sob story which like i said they all do
and i'm not saying
that his uh
you know childhood wasn't horrible it
sounds like it was
um but again not really an excuse
i mean and i don't know how much of it
is exaggerated
you know what i'm saying because a lot
of it just come kind of comes from him
so he's like basically uh he's like yeah
i have a really evil side
uh that i can't always control uh it's
because my dad
who was a cop was real real abusive
um abused his mom abused him abused his
brother
seemed pretty horrific he also said he
had been
raped in prison i don't know if that's
true uh he also kind of blamed his
ex-wife because of course he did
um so so danny and bobby they decide
that the best plan of action to escape
from prison is danny is somehow gonna
fake suicide and then that's they're
gonna take him out and then he's gonna
be like no i'm alive then he's gonna run
away i don't know what their [ __ ]
plan was
he's not like the brightest bulb so that
was kind of what their plan was
uh obviously that never took place
um what he decided to do instead this is
so weird
like i said this dude is so weird i
can't and not even weird in a way that i
can get a handle on it's just weird in
the way that i can't like figure out
what his [ __ ] deal is well gary
ridgway's like that
did you just sit there and look at you
like mm-hmm
i didn't want to say anything yeah yeah
i've seen videos of him being
interviewed
and he just came across as being just a
weasley wimpy
just weak weak [ __ ] worm of a man
saying you know what i mean around the
cops he was just [ __ ] trembling
this [ __ ] killed all these women
and he's going to be scared around the
cops what the [ __ ]
where'd you think you were going to end
up yeah i don't think they think it's a
reason
oh that clearly
he's one of those probably maybe i
didn't see him myself
yeah i mean he wasn't like he wasn't a
small dude he was a pretty big dude
doesn't matter
that's what i mean it's just he didn't
he didn't seem snively he just seemed i
don't know
the battery tall dude should do that
same [ __ ] [ __ ]
they got big cowards too and he just
sounds like a [ __ ] coward
and a lot of times what they'll do is is
they'll just hide behind like a wall of
silence and oh i don't know i don't know
they just kind of act submissive
you know i've seen the interviews of it
yeah
so you know and i like to size them up
you know
this is back when i was [ __ ] into
that kind of [ __ ] i'd walk and watch
them all the time like when i was
watching
klinsky's [ __ ] that was the only
offender that [ __ ]
would have spooked me koklansky the
iceman
well because he wasn't doing it for the
same reason
i would have called that [ __ ] mr
kaklinsky
okay that's how much that dude kind of
[ __ ] shook me
that was a [ __ ] that was like luca
brazi out of the dude worse than luca
brazie out of the godfather
yeah much worse big [ __ ] just
killed all those people yeah mafia hit
man yeah
but uh he was [ __ ] that dude was
tough i'm getting off caught topic but
yeah we already did a show about that
guy yeah
[Laughter]
but that's the only dude that [ __ ]
i'd ever called mr kuklinski
i called him mister but he was doing it
for a profession
these other yeah like i said it's not
like he was doing it because it's like
oh that's my sexual purpose right right
these dudes
got sexual problems you know yeah that's
yeah this [ __ ] got sexual
problems
or something yeah so so at this point
well you know some of these guys they'll
never
really compete with me and what i do i
mean they have no standards
i can tell just by just by you telling
me about this man
jenny is that he didn't care how tall
the grass was
and right there that tells you that
tells you he's got no standards
it certainly does
[Laughter]
doesn't care how tall the grass is
doesn't care where the dogs are
just a total total you know
damaging the community no respect for
the community
sure yeah and the church
yeah yeah see my review on the clue
pitch
yeah go ahead and go back go ahead and
go back i'll stand him back
you set him back wherever to back to the
shelf yeah send him back to prison
okay i can't channel him anymore yeah
he went back to the presidency yeah he's
possessing you but he's still alive yeah
yeah yeah i got paid for that see got a
super chat
that's coming thank you very much
a channel dennis raider sometimes well
well i'm very popular everybody loves me
the women love me of course
five dollars is going to come dennis i
told you go back to prison bro i can't
i'm the only the world's only paranormal
psychic that can channel the living
they got a lot of [ __ ] paranormal
psychics that can channel the dead i
channel the living
yes it's much harder straight from
behind bars
[Laughter]
well of course i have to show up when
you call me tom and
jenny's here both of her boobs are here
i'm not
sure so that'd be pretty weird if one of
them showed up jenny
hold on hold on i'm gonna go get
brian amplin says remember when tom
broke his head off yeah
sophie was here i couldn't believe that
that was like unbelievable we were just
like looked at the floor like oh my god
his head popped up
jenny how can i
how can i refuse tom's request to have
me on the show
when it's you me tom and both of your
boobs
it's not possible it would not be right
if i did not
make an appearance sure i can see that
the audience of course loves me
[Laughter]
they have no choice you know you know
how it is
it's one of my projects yeah well yeah
you've seen my photography
i have the best photography known to man
[Laughter]
you saw me in the fishnets right i i did
how'd it look
um interesting
[Laughter]
it aroused you didn't
[Laughter]
i was aroused when i put the fish nets
on and
went down into that grave it takes a
genius to take a picture of yourself
in a grave dressed up in the fishnets in
the bra
do you ask how hard it is to press that
button
it took me a long time to figure that
out
i had to record i had to record it for
posterity
so everyone would know how beautiful
how beautiful they look to me in my mind
[Laughter]
that's how i become the things that i
love
because i love me yeah that's pretty
clear
and you see unlike other
people like me that have projects i
identify
with these beautiful women every time i
kill one of them
a little piece of myself dies along with
them so
i have to pretend like i'm them at the
same time
i am them i see my own face in theirs
it's very deep it's sentimental you know
about sentiments don't you jenny
sure okay well
chow time i gotta get back
[Laughter]
i got a card game i got to play
some [ __ ] trying to sell me for
a pack of cigarettes
is it h.h holmes he's back there too
yeah yeah yeah h.h helms is trying to
leave yeah
they're [ __ ] with each other i put
them next to each other so they can
fight
yeah yeah all right brian says just get
a sharpie and draw that raider hair on
top
it's just lines oh my god that would be
so [ __ ] funny
tila just showed up and said oh my god i
just showed up and you're playing with
action figures caleb we were talking
about you we were missing you [ __ ]
where the [ __ ] were you
yeah i can't understand like hours did
the whole show you weren't here people
were worried about you in the comments
section i saw me so i'm worried about
tita where is she
well because probably because we're
talking about serial killers probably
just like somebody
make sure yeah you know what i mean yeah
that's [ __ ] up
projects you know projects projects yeah
oh god tom told me about you
i'd like a picture send a picture to me
i want to see if i can reproduce that oh
my goodness yeah
jesus christ yeah uh i don't know i
don't know if taylor knows
has met dennis yet yeah i can't remember
that i don't think they don't
i don't think so i had totally forgotten
about the show when sophie was here when
you dropped dennis and his headphones
off
he was funny that was right
yeah he got fixed he's like the only
he's the only one that copy headed and
it's like still alive
oh yeah it's too i'm playing with action
figure no t no tila
the spirit of i channeled the spirits of
not only the dead but the living i
channel the spirit of dennis raider
and i got a little dent right here and i
started talking about really
yeah we have we still haven't figured
out an hh holmes voice though because we
have an hh home spot no i didn't change
homes
yeah see that's what i see i thought he
would sound like an old school like
carnival
yeah yeah i don't know if that's what he
really sounded like but it's like that
mustache kind of makes me think that
that's probably what he sounded like
yeah
step right up i kind of feel like you're
telling me we've got 71 people in here
listening to us this is the biggest show
of all time
wow thank you very much how exciting
yeah
okay jay jay marcus was in there going
oh dennis
fourth door down said if you hold the
barcode reader up to dennis raider's
hair you get a year's free netflix
damn didn't know that
yeah oh my god i'm tired oh my god
that's awesome how you been jay where
you been jay
oh my god brian says what spirits does
jenny channel
she's vodka yeah that's about
it the vodka and sometimes whiskey yeah
look at that puppy down there sitting at
the feet of spock is she really
mirror spot oh she's hanging in there
all right so where was i
satiko so you're going to have a seance
night one of these you know what i
wanted to do that on one of these
we should you know what we should do
that on the halloween show because we're
running out of ideas for [ __ ] to do for
the halloween show
difficult we'd have to have more than us
here we'd have to [ __ ] get
gin to beach or something well we could
get like more people and also
i probably shouldn't say this out loud
but probably we should like rig up some
[ __ ] like scary [ __ ] to
put in the background because otherwise
it would just be really boring unless
i was sitting around the thing going
like you pushed it do you push now
you're embarking you're embarking on
something that will [ __ ]
lead to bad things okay what you you
actually think that like
demons are gonna come
but that's what everybody wants to see
yeah everybody comes and
watches us for the shenanigans yeah
shenanigans in there act like a hall
monitor asking for people's passes
jay she's in okay but she had some
relatives sick in the hospital
oh [ __ ] don't be all right baby yeah
yeah it happened okay should we go ahead
and get back to the case
yeah we should probably yeah t jumped in
what the [ __ ] is this
no it goes way back t you haven't been
listening to the show long enough i
guess but every now and then
every now and then you haven't done it
only used to do it like every week all
the
time
the spirit of dennis raider takes over
me
even though he's still alive even though
he's still alive i'm one i'm one of the
few psychics that can channel the
spirits of the living
sure they got a lot of mental channel
the spirits that have done this easy
that's [ __ ] everybody can do that i
channel a [ __ ] spirit while he's
still alive
all right so i wonder now i wonder what
happens
to dennis in prison like when you're
when his spirit isn't does he just like
go catatonically
no he doesn't even know what happens he
doesn't even know it's always into like
in two places at once yeah what happens
is
it i'm channeling it through his
unconscious
the cosmic unconscious is not right it
gets up
yeah it gets hot
don't get me started
brian says contact richard ramirez we
don't want to talk to them no
not his teeth were too bad it'd give me
really bad breath and [ __ ]
yeah what if you got like something yeah
he had him rotten teeth he was all
stanky
okay got another super chat is from dc
sent a ten dollar
super chat thank you and he says now
five ten
because i think tom is actually
channeling btk
it is it is for real that's for real i
mean i'm just kind of hoping that he
doesn't channel the murdery part
like one day and he just decides no he's
in a good mood
you know btk yeah but that's probably
bad though because i
feel like he's in about he's in a good
mood when he gets to kill people right
look i got to see if they let these
inmates have [ __ ] phones nowadays
he might have a phone and a connection
are you going to call him and do this
call him and do it
[Laughter]
sending a magnificent 10 sorry i'm late
the devil made me do it i find myself
okay thank you very much
[Laughter]
yeah we're more than halfway through
this show yeah well i mean like i said
they were asking about you they're
they're worried about you
yeah i forgot who it was yeah victor
said jenny's gonna get home and find tom
in her clothes and he's gonna say he's
channeling dennis
yeah yeah that'd shock me yeah he'll be
i'll be i'll come home from vacation
he's gonna be laying on the floor and my
fish nets and
yeah [ __ ] like that like trying to take
a picture of himself like a wig and
whatever
victor's rocking up over that victor's
rocking up over that [ __ ]
he's gay he'd love to see me in some
fishnets all laid out in drag
that would be funny should i could you
should actually shoot like that'd be
funny as [ __ ]
probably but yeah i'd do a recreation
you got to dig a hole in the backyard
dig the hole
[Laughter]
and make that a 13 o'clock [ __ ]
commercial
me in the hole you throwing dirt on me
snapping picture i'm [ __ ]
snapping picture channel i'm channeling
dennis
brought panties that [ __ ] would be funny
it would be fun it'd be real [ __ ] fun
it's got pookie next to me going what
the [ __ ] is going on
can i throw dirt on him too mom of
course you can
yeah because that's what i tell pookie
all the time because cookie likes to
wrestle him
yeah like i said if she if he tries to
like get away from her she like grabs
his legs like no you're not going
anywhere yeah
so i always have like [ __ ] beat him
up get him yeah
i always i always tell bookie to beat
him up yeah should [ __ ] attack my
[ __ ] [ __ ] attack my foot i'm watching
television and i'll [ __ ] get her and
roll her over and just put my hand on
her stomach and she goes
[Laughter]
screaming like i'm killing her or just
touching her [ __ ] stuff
and she's looking at me dead in the eye
going ah and i start doing it back ah
he loves the screen she gets tired of it
and goes okay it starts falling
[ __ ] funny cat that was fun how to
get it to get the video of that [ __ ] she
does it every day
yeah it's like it's a little routine
yeah it's every [ __ ] day
grab my stomach ah you're killing me
yeah yeah oh it'll bite you i'm gonna
bite you
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy she rolls all
her
yeah yeah yeah it's [ __ ] funny it's
so [ __ ] funny it's like a little kid
man yeah she's like a little kid
yeah she is like a little yeah she's
like a little
little tomboy yeah yeah so
okay so here's this weird [ __ ] right so
so the whole fake suicide escape prison
obviously that's gonna work out
so what danny rowling decides to do like
in january
late january of 1993 rather
he tells uh the authorities that he
wants to confess
but he's not gonna confess he's going to
have this
his friend and this other inmate bobby
lewis he's like i want to confess
through him right
so they set it up and it took three
hours
so the investigators would ask
bobby the questions and then bobby would
answer the questions and then danny
would be like
that's right yeah three hours it went on
like that
and so i guess bobby knew all the
details because danny had told him
so it's like dave's just like yeah
that's that's right that's what he said
what did what
he was talking about wouldn't buffalo
bill be an easy [ __ ] costume for
christmas cause all you gotta do is just
tuck and go
yeah there you go just put on the wig
and the little robe
would you [ __ ] me i'd [ __ ] me sing
goodbye horses
i'm dying over you
would you [ __ ] me i'd [ __ ] me yeah
it'd also would be kind of funny if you
carried a basket with lotion in it
yeah yeah it puts the lotion in the
basket break it
or get the hose again
a census taker once tried to take a
census taker
[Laughter]
tell me something agent starling did he
sodomize you
yeah what did mig say to you
meds in the next cell
he said i can smell your [ __ ] i see
myself cannot
crazy that's a great [ __ ] movie i
can't believe we haven't talked about it
although like i said it's uh i would
probably just recite the whole thing
because
you've like seen it so many times
actually i liked hannibal rising
that was a good one a real good one yeah
that was a classy ass [ __ ] movie it
was
a classio it was it was a european movie
it was all
historically correct the guns the enemy
the tanks the world war
ii stuff it was it's a good movie i
liked it
it was a crafted movie
not like one of those just thrown
together pieces no no they
that movie was made with love yeah it
was that was yeah
silence of the lambs is in my top five
of all time yeah yeah same t if you
haven't seen hannibal rising man you
need to see that one
that was when they were all good that's
when hannibal was a kid
how he became that it's pretty good
how he identified with samurai how they
were head takers and cut people's heads
off to get paid
because that's how you got paid from
your liege lord you had to prove that
you
scored kills in combat the only way to
prove that was heads
man but the thing is dudes were cheating
they were cutting the heads off of
dead bodies that other people killed and
then they'd sometimes betray their
friend to cut his head off to get the
money
well yeah i mean everyone is money
involved yeah heads
you're gonna you're gonna see that yeah
yeah you know yeah
futile japanese [ __ ] combat was
corrupt
you gotta [ __ ] read the history to
know
that it wasn't sounds cool on the
surface but they cheated a lot
yeah yeah right hannibal rising i
haven't seen that one yet added to watch
listen somebody mentioned it oh man
somebody mentioned manhunter too which
actually i saw a long time ago i loved
it and it's like i want to watch uh
hannibal hannibal rising is the second
best one i put that
i put that right there with hannah with
with uh the first one
silence of the lambs better in some ways
i like it better
it's an origin story it feels kind of
like an evil batman
really because he's kind of a hero in it
trying to get vengeance for what
happened to his sister his sister misha
that i ain't gonna [ __ ] spoil it
you'll see it messi
so he saw himself as a hero
don't all the villains see themselves
hey there's louie
louie you want to show your ass up in
here okay
you missed dennis and everything yeah
dennis was here he left
he might come back later maybe because
we're talking about serial killers
yeah so okay so like i said so danny
rowling is confessing to the crimes but
indirectly like he's confessing to the
crimes through somebody else like the
other guy is describing everything and
he's been like yeah yeah i totally did
that
um one thing that he said and i don't
think i believe this
but he said um yeah my original plan
back when i was in prison in the 80s um
was
i was gonna kill like my goal right it's
good to have goals uh was that he was
gonna kill
eight people um because that was how
many years he had spent in prison
so it was kind of like a thing uh
because like i said
we'll get into this later but he uh
probably killed those three people
in shreveport too so three people in
shreveport five people in gainesville
that's eight people
um i don't think that he actually
planned to kill
any number of people i think he just did
it and he wasn't thinking about it
and then he got caught you know what i
mean so i don't think he had any
i don't think he had a [ __ ] plan or
anything oh you're gonna miss the best
part
[Laughter]
yeah so like i said i i don't think that
that's true i don't think he had a plan
to kill eight people or anything like
that
also at this session
um he also said
that it wasn't because remember earlier
i said he said that oh i have this evil
side okay well
he kind of said that it's not
me that's doing this i have this
essentially
evil alter ego uh called
gemini now you guys
probably have seen exorcist three
right so had the cops so
the cops knew that from various
investigation and stuff like that some
of them had seen exorcist three
and they also knew that danny rowling
had just seen exorcist three also
uh pretty much the same around the same
time the murders had taken place or
shortly afterward so they're like yeah
we know that that's where you got the
idea because in that movie if you
haven't seen it
um the killer is named gemini
and actually he does some of the same
types of mutilations that
danny rowling did with the beheading and
disemboweling and all that kind of stuff
uh
so he tried to fob off
his crimes on an evil alter ego named
gemini that he got from exorcist three
so there you go
uh now after this took place like after
this
uh confession uh bobby
gets moved to another ward
and at this point i guess danny got like
pissed off at him because he's like oh
well
you just kind of used me to get i don't
know i guess
he thought that bobby was like kissing
ass with the cops so he could like get
moved to a
better area i don't really know uh but
so then he
takes up with this other dude named
rusty benstead
which is a terrible name but whatever
and to this guy you missed the part
where i said that
danny rowling tried to blame the crimes
on an evil alter ego called gemini
just like in exorcist three okay yeah
yeah i got a zodiac it's like a zodiac
it's like a gemini
ripoff of the zodiac yeah yeah yeah it
was
exorcist three he had just seen extras
those three so that's why he's right
just in case they might be able to
believe some [ __ ] like that well no
because the cops were like yeah
they're like every side nice try
but uh yeah so he starts hanging out
with this other dude rusty benstead
and he does essentially the same thing
like i'm gonna give you all the details
of all these horrible crimes i committed
but this time he wrote it all down so
he writes it all down in a letter he
gives it to rusty
um he's like make a copy of this and
then give me the original back
you know what i mean yeah uh but what
rusty did was that he went back to his
cell
and then he like waits five minutes and
then he yells shake down
and then he starts flushing the toilet
because he wanted
uh he wanted danny to think that he had
flushed the letter down the toilet so
like the authorities wouldn't find it
except really he kept it um
so i see you in there louie what's up
bro yeah they just got here
yeah russell you want to show up and
[ __ ]
show up towards the end of the show
after i already did all kinds of funny
[ __ ] you missed it you can go back and
watch the [ __ ] recorded well the drunker
you get like you'll probably get funnier
at some point
it's gonna be all right
that's what you always say uh
so three weeks before the trial
danny asks to meet with his uh attorney
why don't you stand here pull gets hot
outside she's pulling on you
outside she just likes to pull on things
no she's like yeah let's go
okay let's go you better go this time
i mean you know we'll see how it goes
her little friend came by last night
i woke up at two or three in the morning
and i heard me
like outside the window and it's weird
because like the the kitty the other
kitty
the one that looks like pookie that has
a but has a tail it's like she comes to
the
back porch and calls her
but then like pookie just runs to the
window and stares at her
like she doesn't call to her she doesn't
do anything
it's like really weird they have like
the weirdest relationship
uh okay so so danny rowling like meets
with his attorney
three weeks before the trial is supposed
to start and he says i want to plead
guilty now his lawyer as as most of them
would
said uh yeah no there is a lot of uh
evidence against you i'm not gonna say
that
because there was um and you know you
did that confession and the letter and
everything
you know the confession that was
videotaped and the letter that you wrote
down and you said that you did all this
stuff and
also they have a bunch of other you know
physical evidence but
um they said maybe uh you know there's
mitigating factors you got abused this
that and the other
uh so maybe you'll be able to worm your
way out of a death sentence but not if
you plead
guilty um and that's what the defense
attorney essentially
said like that they wanted to do they
said look you know you come from a
family that was like very abusive your
dad was very abusive
um you know you had all these terrible
things happen to you
uh so we could use that like to just get
you life in prison i mean he was gonna
get life in prison anyway just on the
[ __ ] uh
burglary and armed robbery charges uh
so it they didn't even really have to
convict him of the murders he would have
still been in prison for the rest of his
life but
they were uh the prosecution was looking
for the death penalty
so but they were so the defense were
basically like yo look you're
going to prison whether you like it or
not um because you've already been like
convicted this other [ __ ]
but we could at least try to get you
from keep you from being executed
um but you know he's like you you
wouldn't be able to like over
you know you would be able to appeal the
conviction i guess so like the that's
the way the laws work
um but at this point like danny was like
no i still want to plead
guilty and he said the reason that he
gave
for wanting to plead guilty was he
thought that if he had to go to trial
like an open court that they would show
photographs of the crime scenes
and he didn't want anyone seeing them
and i'm not really sure exactly why like
i don't know if he was like
ashamed of them or
like he thought maybe his family would
be there and like they wouldn't i don't
really know like what his
this is what i mean it's like he just
had these really weird like thought
processes
i don't really get why he thought well
i'm just gonna plead guilty because i
don't want anybody seeing those photos
you know what i mean yeah uh so the
so the attorney was like well you know i
don't like the idea but whatever just
like think about it there's still
three weeks to go now
danny apparently he didn't change his
mind though so the week before the trial
uh he signs the uh the form and uh that
was his
official guilty plea um
so basically that's what he did he just
so it was like kind of a last minute you
know kind of thing or you know just
i guess it saved everybody a lot of
money you know what i mean yeah
so they so they still ironically
they still have to have the thing where
you know they
they come in there and he has to plead
guilty and it's like the official
whatever
um but it wasn't like open court there
was no you know jury or anything it was
just like families of the victims were
there
um you know some members of the public
were there not much media anything
um none of danny rowling's family showed
up because
you know why would they um now
somebody brought this person up before
but they said the only person that was
there
uh that was on his side was sandra
london who was his fiancee
now she and danny
i guess they had struck up a friendship
she is one of those kind of like serial
killer groupies
that like kind of starts right into him
in prison but
she's a true crime writer as well and so
i think that her whole thing was she was
trying to get [ __ ] out of him and like
get a book out of him so they authored a
book together
i think it was called the making of a
serial killer or something like that
uh and they wrote that together and they
i don't know did they ever get married i
can't remember but they were like
engaged for a while
and she i mean she would like defend him
all the time and he would like defend
her all the time and how much she loved
her and all this other kind of stuff it
was super super weird like that whole
[ __ ] situation
um i mean i honestly i'm not saying like
he's a piece of [ __ ] too but i
you know and who cares what the [ __ ]
happened to him but
you know she was just trying to get the
story out of him
and get a book written and make some
money off it you know what i mean
yeah it was just that kind of situation
but she was the only one that showed up
um so basically yeah so he pleaded
guilty to the five murders
um he later came forward i think before
his execution he later came forward and
said that he had done the
uh the murders in shreveport as well the
triple homicide of the family
but i don't think they ever i mean
nobody ever brought charges against him
for that because he was already
imprisoned for
all of the other [ __ ] things he did
um
so how many total was it that he killed
uh five that he was convicted for and
probably three more
okay and that's that they know of and
out of that five one of me cut the head
off
yes there's the head and the nipples off
the same one or is that nipples yeah
another one
okay headed nipples off the same one and
and the other the first two girls also
had breast mutilations
he was a similar nature
weird and the third victim
was not mutilated but that's because the
maintenance man opened the door
like probably while he was still there
and so he got just like jack the ripper
he got run off
right um you know what i mean so i don't
know what he was planning on doing with
that one it probably would have been
even worse
it's funny he didn't confront a
maintenance man must been a big dude
well i don't know if it was so it's like
i don't think that i think all he heard
was the door open and closed real quick
he knew and he didn't know who it was
because he didn't i mean when the
maintenance man came in he all he saw
was the body
yeah and the bag he didn't see the guy
kind of cowardly
yeah he just like when he came back five
minutes later he noticed the door was
locked and the bag was gone so he's like
oh the killer must have been there
raider would have just said who was
coming in here and then when that dude
walked into it
would have killed him yeah and i mean
you know
danny rowling did kill one dude but he
killed the dude while he was sleeping
right his whole thing was he would jump
on you with the
combat knife and he would just like stab
the [ __ ] out of you until you were
asleep a lot while you were asleep
now casper i mean the um this cowardice
that's somebody who can't face anybody
else i mean the dude did wake up
manny did wake up because there were a
lot of defensive wounds on his arms
yeah but he had been stabbed so many
times by that point that he was just
bleeding out
i've seen photographs of him he just
doesn't look like a man of physical
courage in any way you know just
no no it's just it's just [ __ ] i
i i find these [ __ ] slimy they
rape and kill people
but at the same time in this particular
case especially kind of
afraid of facing a person
while they're awake yeah they're much
more like hey i want to sneak up on you
sneak up on you and get an advantage and
kill you quickly
yeah weird not weird it's not weird it's
it's understandable it's a sign of
weakness
other serial killers [ __ ] don't won't
do it that way
yeah keep him around point guns at him
[ __ ] torture him for a while
i mean they would deal with them face to
face but this is a dude who doesn't
really want to
ridgeway was like that he he couldn't
deal with them face to face
yeah just strangled from behind and i
don't really know it's like you know
this dude
danny rowling also grew up in a really
really abusive
uh household as well um apparently like
i said his dad was a cop and used to
like beat up on
him and his mom and everything like that
and
i don't know and so i kind of feel like
it's weird because yeah but i feel like
a lot of these types of serial killers
and this is something that we've seen in
a lot of different
you know shows that we've done is that a
lot of times when these
uh serial killers are kids and a lot of
them are abused by their dads
for whatever reason um when they get
older and start killing people they
always take
their rage out on women and i think it's
because
you know maybe to some extent yes it may
be because women are more available or
they're
you know physically smaller or whatever
but i think some of it too
is they seem to like you said not be
able to face another man
so they can't get back at their dad
because he's the same size so they kind
of displace their rage onto their mom
because mom didn't protect me from dad
and i kind of feel like that was the
situation here cam guy says there was a
bank shootout in los angeles where two
perps were walking around and stopped
traffic
i think he's talking about what was that
the west los angeles
shootout about of the 90s that yeah you
wanted to do a show about that i wanted
to do a
show on about it yeah it's in my uh
topic yeah that's a very interesting
case
um i think the movie heat was slightly
based on that in a certain way there
were just some brazen
bank robbers one dude whose name was
emil and um
he had a pretty cool custom-made ar-15
they were both bodybuilders those dudes
were [ __ ] 200 and something pounds
both of them
six foot one six foot two well didn't we
see that other movie that was kind of
based on that
i don't think so uh what what other
movie
wasn't pain and gain kind of based on
that a little bit or no
no no that was uh there was something
else i was thinking of
oh thank you mango has raider gone away
can i come out the closet yet hail for
the always amazing
thank you very much how much did he have
25 25 thank you very much
thank you very much the um
yeah i wanted to do this it's called the
west hollywood shootout this i think is
what it was called
they hit several banks that was just the
one that got caught out they were fully
armored with body armor and everything
and they went toe-to-toe with the lapd
and there's a lot of [ __ ]
i watched that [ __ ] live as it happened
and um
there was a lot of testimony from people
that
were there at the time and the testimony
wasn't recorded the [ __ ] that emel and
stuff was saying
because i went back to see it and they
censored it a lot
they were using psychological warfare
against the [ __ ] cops
[ __ ] every time the cops would shoot
out of em will turn at them with that
[ __ ] ar-15 start [ __ ] opening up
on him and
every time he fired he would say [ __ ]
like get down get down
and he would use uh i guess you guys a
slur against
gay people that starts with an f and he
would retur he would
[ __ ] you know he would call the cops
[ __ ] as he was [ __ ] shooting at
him
and he was just fierce [ __ ]
they were on all kinds of
performance-enhancing drugs and i think
it was methamphetamine
it would amp them oh no they i think
they did
meth for they did methamphetamines
but then right before the uh the robbery
they would
take a bunch of sedatives to try to
chill themselves out and they were like
in this weird
drug equilibrium
uh that's a really interesting case it's
a good thing you bring that up we should
we need to do a show on that yeah like i
said i really i know it's on the topic
list
because i remember when you said it at
night i remember watching it live and
hearing dudes
hearing people in the news saying what
they were saying and everything they
were just
they were big dudes very intimidating
they would go into a bank and [ __ ] slap
people around and [ __ ]
shoot the money and [ __ ] they were
takeover robbers
totally inefficient totally
unprofessional
and they got killed eventually i mean
that's not how you rob a bank it was
just how they imagined you rob a bank
they were bodybuilders on [ __ ] a
bunch of roids and they just kind of
they loved guns and they hated
california because california
banned guns and that was part of their
vengeance
just interesting dudes they didn't kill
anybody that's the weird thing they
didn't kill anybody
but they put a lot of people in danger
they shot people but they lived
yeah good that'll make a good show
yeah we should probably do that i can
put that when i get back i'll put at one
of the polls yeah cause like i said it's
not gonna be polls this week because
i'm gonna be gone so we already recorded
everything i give those two a [ __ ] a
plus for balls
but kind of like c minus for brains they
you know they have balls but they don't
have balls
so yeah so even though uh danny's
defensively
like i said he did plead guilty but his
defense attorney was trying to argue
at this point like i said he was already
gonna get life in prison
anyway uh because of all the armed
robbery charges
the only uh argument they were making is
not giving him the death penalty
so they were trying to like argue
mitigating circumstances
um you know [ __ ] like he was abused as a
child
he had a history of drug and alcohol
abuse he showed remorse
sort of um you know what i mean uh
also even though danny had pleaded
guilty because he didn't want the crime
scene photos like shown to
the court or shown to the public or
whatever uh they still
the prosecution still did that anyway so
you know that's what i mean
uh because you know the prosecution was
trying to get the death penalty so
they're like well we need all this
ammunition like against him so we're
going to show like what the [ __ ] he did
right
um and they also had all the like i said
all the physical evidence they
did find out that his dna matched um
the semen that they found at three of
the sites uh
like i said they found uh the
screwdriver that matched the [ __ ] they
found
duct tape that also matched uh the
sticky
residue like at the sum of the sites
also they found a pair at the campsite
they found a pair of pants that had
manny's
blood on it which was the fourth victim
so you know
and uh you know like i said they all all
the [ __ ] [ __ ] that they found
so at this stage um
you know so the prosecution's arguing
yeah we we should
kill this [ __ ] because these
crimes were
particularly what they call heinous and
cruel
meaning that um you know
he did a lot of the stuff post-mortem
but you have to imagine
he bound these women he raped them
before he did
before he killed them um you know and
then he leaves these bo
the bodies in these [ __ ] horrible
positions like cuts pieces off of them
it's just like [ __ ]
jesus christ so
uh it didn't actually um
[Music]
take all that long for them to decide
that
they were going to give him the death
penalty
even though they told the whole story i
think that his
mom showed up um and kind of gave a
little bit of the backstory about how
abused he was
because like the mom kept leaving the
husband and like having to come back and
[ __ ]
and it was apparent it was not a fun
time i'm sure
um but i think in the end they decided
that really didn't
mitigate the brutality and
just randomness of these [ __ ] crimes
that he committed which like i said he
just committed for no [ __ ] reason
just
he just decided to one day and that's
what he [ __ ] did so
uh they did actually end up uh executing
him
in i believe it was 2006.
uh he finally went to the uh
it was an electric chair they did um
what do you call it
yes no it was a lethal injection lethal
injection i couldn't remember the word
lethal injection and they said he didn't
have any last words
but that uh some of the victims families
turned up to see him executed
and i remember when that happened too
that was 2006.
and um and they said that he just kind
of looked at them
like at the people like watching the
execution and then he started singing
like a hymn
or something like as he died it's not
weird
it's like he's just like [ __ ] weird
ass [ __ ] dude like i said i can't
really i can't get a handle on
his personality he just seems like
somebody that's
not there you know what i mean yeah do
you get what i'm telling
you he sounds to me he's i don't want
him i don't want to [ __ ]
[ __ ] the show up but he's kind of a
boring serial killer in terms of like he
said there's no real personal flair
there he's
working like there's there's just no
individuality to this [ __ ] well
in the sen i mean it was just like
no signature well no i mean the [ __ ]
that he did was horrible
yeah but who is he but yeah he didn't
maybe that's why he didn't capture the
public imagination
even though the [ __ ] that he did was
just as bad as the [ __ ] that bundy did
yeah like [ __ ] leaving people's heads
looking at their headless bodies and
[ __ ] jesus [ __ ] christ cutting
people's nipples off and
[ __ ] it could be that we that that this
case may be a victim of
media blackout where there was a bunch
of
[ __ ] that he said but we don't know
about it and it was never released to
the media so maybe
the case never really got
sensationalized i don't know
i i don't think it's that much yeah he
did he blabbed
uh every single detail of the crimes
like to several people
on tape in letters he's
i just i think that i think like you
said
this is [ __ ] up to say but i think
there's even like a celebrity
aspect to serial killers
um because we've done shows about some
serial killers that dead
that did [ __ ] that was just as horrific
as some of the other more famous ones
but they didn't get famous for whatever
reason
and i think maybe it has something to do
with
not necessarily the brutality of their
crimes or how
horrible they were because a lot of them
were because like i said these crimes
were [ __ ] horrible
he did [ __ ] that was just as bad as what
ted ted bundy did
um but he just
i don't know he just wasn't like a media
sensation i guess yeah like he didn't
have enough
flair or enough like personality or
something i know it's a [ __ ] up thing
to say but
that's kind of the only thing that i can
think of
well you know you got to be fair and re
it may have he may have been
it may have been a product of the time a
lot of the classics that we use
as kind of like a uh as a benchmark
came from the 60s and 70s and the 80s
when it was kind of a newer feeling
phenomenon in the mass media
i mean they've caught some guys in the
past couple years that you don't hear
about it anymore they had some dude that
was
keeping a girl in a damn storage crate
chained up in there and uh there were a
couple other girls buried nearby
and he got busted they saved the girl
they got him out of there and you don't
hear anything about that dude
and he was just out in the country
somewhere it's almost kind of like maybe
there's um
media fatigue or societal fatigue
and the thing about it too is i feel
like when these crimes first happened
and i remember this because like i said
i'm from here
um when they didn't know who it was
the [ __ ] was all over the news because
it was it was
gory it was graphic it's like people got
beheaded their nipples got cut off it's
like you know that's gonna sell papers i
hate to say
but but once they kind of found out who
i think maybe too because in this
situation
because for a long time they were so
used they were they thought it was that
other dude
you know what i mean for for a while um
so maybe
they kind of wasted all their outrage on
that guy like when they thought it was
that guy
and then like later they're like oh
never mind it's not that guy it's this
other guy and they were like man we
don't care anymore because it had
already like [ __ ] passed by maybe
that's why too
just because they thought it was someone
else for so long thank you
no need for me to question for all the
499 super chat right yeah
yeah you always always read out how much
it was well i don't know i don't like to
do that but um if you had to choose the
way you'd be executed what would you
pick
me firing squad or guillotine guilty no
[ __ ] way i have a thing about
beheading i don't like that
it's kind of a crazy question if you
understand the details of death row
those dudes go on death row they'll be
there for [ __ ] years sometimes
decades
here in the united states they're doped
up from the day that they get in there
they keep them on all kinds of sedatives
before the execution date they start
increasing their medications a lot
so they're just they're they're they're
they're very calm
um
i mean they had one dude saying you know
he [ __ ] he he they asked him what he
wanted for his final meal
and he [ __ ] ordered he he ordered all
this [ __ ] you know what i mean and they
brought it to him
and in a dessert and everything was like
a strawberry sundae
and they walk him out to get executed he
didn't eat the sundae and he said what
do you what about that he goes oh i'll
eat it when i come back
we're not coming back he was kind of
mentally challenged
but you know there and he was sucking
also doped up
i'll eat it afterwards just you know
like okay
the best one is the one that they give
you would be lethal injection
yeah i mean that seems like it would be
like because it would be like going
under anesthesia yeah just understand
and i've been gone under anesthesia
before and it's just yeah
there's multiple injections in the first
one just so i can knocks you out
and then they start giving you multiple
lethal injections of a bunch of
different things
on top of that so the first one doesn't
kill you the first one's just
not unconscious so you know that they
know that as they're being executed that
the first one doesn't kill you
so they don't they don't see their
deaths coming
they see the sleep coming they're gonna
die later so it kind of gives them a
psychological out
yeah that's the best way to go
and i mean some people would argue
because of the [ __ ] and actually
um and particularly this case too
because if you remember when ted bundy
got executed there was like a huge
uh thing people were having like bundy
barbecue like outside the [ __ ] prison
or whatever
a similar thing happened with this guy
in 2006 when he got executed
even though it wasn't uh the electric
chair ted bundy got the electric chair i
think
yeah um but you know i think i don't
know why you'd want the electric chair
well that's what we used to happen yeah
that's they didn't give him a choice
no there wasn't a choice back then uh it
was old sparky or nothing that's what
they used to call it old sparky
um but yeah we went to lethal injection
i can't remember what year i'd have to
look on wikipedia i remember when it
happened but i can't remember what year
it was
i'm getting old everything's fuzzy but
um i don't even remember what i was
saying where i was going with that
but um oh what i was gonna say was that
you know it was the same thing where a
lot of people came
to the [ __ ] and they interviewed because
i read a whole bunch of articles like
from new york times and stuff when they
executed him and they interviewed a lot
of the um
victims families and most of the victims
families uh had
come to see the execution but a lot of
them said the same thing it's like his
death was so easy
like compared to their loved ones and
they didn't really like that
because they're like you know he just
went to sleep singing to him tila asked
earlier if he
came from a religious background yes he
did um
he was actually pretty his family was
kind of religious and then he was kind
of
uh pretty active in the church and that
kind of stuff so yeah
he was like from a thank you david
read what grampur said from trenton uh a
friend of mine from trenton is a prison
guard at the huron valley
psychiatric prison in is uh yeah i know
uh michigan he says it's a cake job all
the inmates are on thorazine
yeah thor's in turn you know damn living
zombies well i mean you have to
understand that it's like well
people have to work there around those
people and it's like so you want to keep
them as [ __ ] calm as possible i don't
know i don't blame them for putting on
that [ __ ]
that's two dollars super chat david jim
if i had more i donate more love y'all
we love
we love you too all right make sure to
send your information we'll send you a
shirt
yeah i got you written down you know but
yeah so
i don't know i just like i said i'm glad
i finally got to cover this case because
this is one that i
remember happening in real time and it's
just funny because
when i was saying the [ __ ] before about
maybe why this dude isn't so remembered
is because there was that other suspect
for a long time that was just splashed
all over the media
and i think people remember that guy
more like i said because his face was
all scarred up you know
and i even remember back from that time
period when that happened
and everybody being like oh there's the
guy they got him
and then it was a long time before it
kind of
was sorted out that it's like oh it
wasn't him and it was this other dude
and i think everybody had gotten so used
to the first guy
being the killer even though he wasn't
that when the real killer got caught
they were just kind of like
you know what i mean it's just kind of
like the thing where you know if you
print
some [ __ ] like you know back in the old
days when these print [ __ ] newspapers
right if you print some [ __ ] in big type
on the front page and then the next day
you figure out you know you figure out
that was wrong and they have to print a
retraction
and then they always print the
retraction like in this little bit
nobody's gonna remember the retraction
they're always going to remember
the big [ __ ] that was on the front page
and
you can't people always kind of remember
the first thing that they
heard and then if they hear like other
contradictory [ __ ] later they don't
remember it
so i think maybe that had something to
do with maybe this why this guy isn't
quite as famous like as ted bundy
not only because he's kind of a
non-entity with no personality
but also because that other dude was a
suspect for such a long time and was
splashed all over the media
and by the time they caught the real guy
everyone had already kind of like
forgotten about it because they thought
oh i thought they caught that guy
already
t asked what state still has the
guillotine i don't think any state has
the guillotine i don't think any state
have to get anymore yeah
they might have i don't even remember
when did any states i'm sure
maybe one but i don't even i don't even
think one state had that if
the state had the if a state in the
union had the guillotine it would be
louisiana
because they had french law they still
have french law it's called napoleonic
law but i don't
even think they ever had it did that
they probably didn't have it i don't
think they did it
yeah yeah some places did have hanging
hanging was the most common one
yeah especially like out west yeah i
remember that
and hanging evidently is instant death
it's not like they hang you and you
choke to death they drop you through a
hole in them
from the hole in the ground and you fall
about five feet and it just snaps your
neck
well it's supposed to that doesn't
always happen evidently it
it kills them it knocks them out because
i've heard of some
criminals that got that that and it
didn't break their neck so they just
basically hung there and suffocated and
it took a long time
they choked and took a long time yeah
well no yeah it does happen i think
you know i think in general everything i
heard that it killed him instantly it
knocked him out because it broke their
neck
basically basically tears the head off
of the body
but it doesn't fall free but it
dislocates the damn spinal cord
it's supposed to be pretty traumatic
[ __ ] you know what i mean
it's just like guillotine
the guillotine the worst part of the
guillotine would probably put your head
in that [ __ ] thing
and then when they pull that trigger
imagine to hear that blade falling and
coming
because that would be horrible i've seen
videos of it
france was using it up into the time of
even [ __ ] that they had filmed i
think they did it
i think they were guillotined in [ __ ]
vichy france
french after the the the german
occupation
i think they actually i think they
killed some of them with dc says 1977
was the last guillotine execution but i
don't know where that was though
i saw it i saw films of it you could see
it on youtube probably
and it was black and white so i think it
was 40s
it's fast when it falls but you know
that dude was [ __ ] screaming as that
damn blade was coming down
now there was some question even back in
the 1700s during during the french
revolution of whether or not that killed
you instantly
and they were running they had bets and
they even had medical doctors and
scientists trying to figure out if that
wasn't
about that [ __ ] so what they would do is
that's what i did
yeah they had some guys that would go to
these executions and stand by that
bucket and that basket
yeah and when the head fell in the
basket they'd pick it up and start
talking to it
and uh slap it yeah slap it yeah slap it
and see if the eyes would open and it
only opened a couple times one doctor
said it opened a couple times
and the and the eyes did look at him and
he one but then it then they closed
again
and one time the eyes looked at him and
the mouth moved
i think what happened is is that when
you take a head off the body that
quickly
blood pressure drops rapidly very
rapidly which would render you very
unconscious
uh you definitely wouldn't feel it it'd
feel like being hit by a truck
probably you'd be stunned
and i don't think you'd be conscious i
think it was
i think it was nerves basically
well i guess there's really no way of
knowing no way well
the rapid depressurization is yeah and
that makes me nice i don't think it
could ever be rapid enough for me though
the blood pressure drops [ __ ]
instantly gotta be [ __ ] horrifying
yeah well i don't know well the thing
about it is that it wouldn't even be so
much
the actual [ __ ] as like the thinking
about it beforehand maybe the
worst part the worst part is to be tied
up and have them put you
lay you down on that bench and slide you
forward and your head to go in that damn
dished out thing and then to [ __ ] put
the put that wooden
section over the back part of your head
and your head being trapped in there
knowing they're knowing that the next
thing that happens that that blade falls
yep and then to hear that blade falling
on the track
like a train coming back
but if you're in punched or if you ever
been [ __ ] hit or motorcycle accidents
[ __ ] like that happens so fast you're
not really aware what the hell's going
on you know what i mean
i mean you're like what the hell i like
to think like your brain
most of the time yeah if you're if it
knows that you're going to go through
something like
some bad [ __ ] you know you're freaking
out it usually well i mean sometimes
it'll kind of like
because you know how sometimes like
people be in car accidents and stuff and
then later
um they'll be like i can't i can't
remember anything yeah
that's kind of your brain's uh gift to
you
yeah is because it's just better some
things are just better not to remember
i'm just saying that as long as i
can remember i have been
fascinated slash horrified by beheading
we're losing any limb really kind of
like freaks me out which is why like i
said when we were talking about that
michael caine movie the hand
i said that's why that movie always
freaked me out because
i could think about that happening like
sticking your hand out the window and
get your hand cut off by a truck or
whatever
and that scene in the omen where david
warner gets his head cut off by the pane
of glass
that used to scare the [ __ ] out of me as
a kid because i first saw that movie
when i was like seven or eight and i was
just like no
oh my god that scared me so bad so i was
always
but then the weird thing about it is
that it like terrified me but i always
wanted to like read about it
like you know the whole [ __ ] about who
was it like mary queen of scots or
whoever
yeah and they were doing her execution
in and it was like
it wasn't even the guillotine it was a
big room and they were just gonna have
like the executioner come with the axe
or whatever
and he missed well he didn't miss
he hit her but it didn't cut her head
off and she was still conscious
and i that story just
[ __ ] just [ __ ] me up because that's
all i could think about was her laying
that [ __ ] on the
on the block and then him doing that and
being like oh i didn't get it quite
and she was just like [ __ ] me that sucks
yeah
and then he cuts around it's like
oh that's awful louis says i've seen
videos of the mexican cartels
decapitating people with a chainsaw i
saw one video where they were
took the chainsaw and they had they had
two dudes and a woman
tied up the hands behind the back they
just went up that chainsaw and they just
and the neck just cut a few inch slice
in the top of the neck with a chainsaw
it then they just lost they bled out and
died
saw that uh the one that really [ __ ]
there were two videos that are kind of
like that that [ __ ] me up one of them
was something from
i think bosnia the bosnia herzegovina
deer during that damn bosnian civil war
where a dude jumped on dude they had
they had it
they had a dude tied up to a chair
they knocked that chair over and jumped
on top of him dude took a [ __ ]
bayonet i don't know if there were
mercenaries or soldiers there was some
the guy was wearing a uniform took a
bayonet and slowly shoved it through the
side of a guy's head and that dude
[ __ ] screamed through that whole
[ __ ] thing that was back in the 90s
that one was like whoa
another one is where a cartel guy
they had a woman tied up he tells the
camera this is what happened to rats you
know she ratted us out is what happens
to rats
and he had a just a buck knife
and she was tied up and he [ __ ] got
up next to her and started cutting her
head off with a buck knife
and he went in slowly like that and just
cut her head off while she was alive
and and what was really [ __ ] freaky i
had to wince
look which oh oh like damn
and what was weird about it is that she
didn't make a [ __ ] peep
she was like a trooper she just
gritted her teeth and just [ __ ]
leaned into it
she didn't give that dude an inch didn't
even [ __ ] scream
just i mean as horrible as that is you
gotta admire balls
yeah she's like i'm not giving you this
action did you give
and then he [ __ ] separated the
vertebrae and then went in through the
other end and [ __ ] cut that head off
and it
he knew he was doing he'd done it before
evidently it didn't take him long to do
it
and she didn't make a [ __ ] peep she's
just
gritting her teeth no man that was weird
that's horrifying yeah
oh she actually worked with him she was
the next she was a cartel member
but she didn't give that dude a [ __ ]
didn't he give
it didn't didn't give that dude any
satisfaction she just leaned into it
that was yeah weird yeah hero
although i i'm gonna repeat uh a
a comment that i saw earlier on some
article about something remember what it
was
but somebody just commented very briefly
humans were a mistake
[Laughter]
i mean you have to understand that man
is a killer ape
that's what they are they're working
very intelligent
very creative there's a lot of beauty in
it
but a lot of that creativity can be
channeled towards
the destruction of enemies and it's not
pretty
but i can gonna get all [ __ ]
friedrich neath nietzsche and arthur
schopenhauer
life is suffering we suffer because we
desire
things and we desire things that will
eventually disappoint us
if we stop desiring these things then we
won't feel disappointment
the only way to feel this only way to
stop desiring things is
to [ __ ] reach nirvana like an
enlightened indifference
and then nietzsche comes along and says
well well [ __ ] that [ __ ]
if that's what life is then [ __ ] live
your life and go down
fighting for what you want and what you
believe in okay
and that life is a struggle it's a
struggle against
everything even time itself is hunting
you down you're gonna die
so you might as well give it your all
and have a [ __ ] good time
and [ __ ] you know what i mean try to
become as strong as you can and
just like don't cut anyone's head off
okay no
but but what but
nietzsche also says that everything is
uh uh
everything is struggled between forces
one force is always trying to struggle
against an opposing force
so conflict is one of the things of life
because whenever you have something
everything you have is
things that you're taking away from
someone else
even the clothes on your back are
clothes that other people may need to
[ __ ] keep themselves alive in cold
weather
you existence itself is wrong because
you
impose on other things just by merely
existing
so don't try to live a righteous life
and a fair life because life itself is
unfair
your existence imposes on other things
get over it and live your [ __ ] life
that's the lesson of it sounds like an
excuse to just like be an [ __ ] though
that is not at all that is not at all
i'm just [ __ ]
it's not at all what he says says i'm
just [ __ ] with you don't get all
serious okay
well i'm trying to say something that is
important
you know what i mean don't worry about
things live your life
someone oh there's always someone
somewhere else that is suffering you
can't help them
even though you want to live your life
don't worry about the sufferings of
others or it'll spoil yours
help them if you can but you can't help
everybody
it's not the way that's not the way the
world is right now there are people
suffering and dying in [ __ ] secret
prisons and [ __ ]
perverts with little children captive
but you don't even know where they are
you can't help them
don't let that bother you that's what
arthur chopin howard would have said he
says don't let it bother you you can't
control that
live your life yeah
yeah um so yeah so vashti was saying
uh that they just learned that you can
suffer from
internal beheading internal behavior so
you look
fine it's only the soft tissue that's
holding your head on yeah you look fine
but your head has actually been removed
from your spine
yeah hanging would do that yeah i can
see that
right that's kind of what i was talking
about that's [ __ ] up pops your head
off yeah break your spinal cord
although like i said there have been
multiple cases
uh you know of criminal people of people
who
yeah it didn't break their neck it
didn't break their neck yeah but they
die anyway
well yeah but i'm just saying it doesn't
break their neck though in the old west
sometimes they would [ __ ] look and
dude was kicking too much they just grab
his legs and pull on him harder
so he would strangle the guy if you ever
been choked out during a wrestling match
it doesn't take long
to choke somebody out into
unconsciousness you know five seconds
maybe
well i mean humans are really not i mean
we have our strengths but yeah you can
like kill us really really easily
yeah like in a ridic you just put a
[ __ ] pillow over somebody's face for
most of them most of those dudes that
were hung especially in the 1800s in the
old west
i'm not going to say europe because in
my understanding they were hanging
people in england for
minor offenses that you would never be
hung for in the u.s
or even in the territories before you
know or even in the colonies they
wouldn't hang you for something that
might
hang you for like horse rustling yeah
but that was the same as attempted
murderer
when you think about it under those
conditions if you stole somebody's
horses
you would kill you were killing them
basically because you couldn't survive
on foot
or no white man could the indians could
so taking somebody's horse was a hanging
offense and that
that's that that made sure that [ __ ]
only very hardcore
offenders were willing to steal horses
yeah that makes sense yeah that was a
survival item
another thing is is that a lot of those
laws per se weren't laws
they're shown as kind of laws in those
wild west movies but they weren't laws
they were in
disputed territories out in the wild
and it was more like tradition
yeah you didn't need law only [ __ ]
need law
i know you took my horse i'm gonna kill
you that's just
the way it was like mad max
yeah yeah
[Laughter]
so uh what else uh no need for me said i
watched the monkey head transplant
experiment
yeah yeah i saw that too what about the
two dog the two-headed dog transplant
that the russians did that was
[ __ ] the dude in charge i have a
harder time watching that than i do
watching people get
executed to be honest with you anytime
they're doing something to an animal i'm
just kind of like
yeah dude did that in russia back in the
50s [ __ ] then dude in charge of that
[ __ ] program saw his
saw that happen he's like don't you ever
[ __ ] transplant another head on a dog
ever again
you knock that off yeah i mean it
shouldn't really need to be said
yeah you can do it it's just that hey
sergey can we not
like yeah don't do that so two dogs
heads on the skin
thanks let's let's not do it with that
anymore okay
bringing him into the office to like i
could tell not to do it anymore
oh my god that's like so [ __ ] funny
in a [ __ ] up way that's really funny
those russkies
yeah it's uh i don't know man
the show's like kind of bummed me out no
it's saying i'm just philosophizing dude
preach on bro yeah of course what else
is there
i've been working in the kremlin with a
two-headed dog sure yeah
um i see you know it's just i don't know
for
i'm just really fascinated like i said
i've always been really fascinated with
beheading and with people who's like
people getting their limbs cut off
because i always thought that has to be
the weirdest [ __ ] ever
like getting your arm cut off let's say
and like in some horrible accident and
then like you're laying there
and it's like this arm that was attached
to your body like presumably your whole
life and now it's over there and it's
like not attached to you anymore
now it's just like an object that's
freaky to me
because you've never been through it
well i know that but i'm just saying
that it's like it's got to be freaky for
anybody
well they've had people that had that
happen to them and then they they shook
it off industrial accidents and stuff
run hit by cars and traffic light girl
that was like surfing and her she got
her arm bit off by a [ __ ] shark yeah
yeah man that little girl was badass
yeah she was just like [ __ ] i'm going
right back to surfing yeah
i was like man you go little girl let's
see what everybody's saying even though
that's the most terrifying thing i could
put well one of the most terrifying
things i can imagine
i was thinking you know what i mean you
know what i i had a nightmare
the other day i guess because i said
because i was excited about i'm excited
about going to the alligator farm in
saint augustine next i've been there
before but it's like really cool
they have other [ __ ] there other than
alligators they have other animals too
but i was like telling him i was like oh
so so excited to go to the alligator
farm
and i had a nightmare i don't think i
told you
i had a nightmare that we were walking
through
it was weird because it was kind of like
a jungley swamp area but then it was
also kind of like a car wash
you know what i mean you know what i
mean have car wash has like those cement
bays it was kind of like that and then
like in the middle of each bay there was
like a little shallow swampy
deal and then some of them had
alligators in there
and then people were walking through
there even though you could walk around
and i didn't understand why people were
walking through there be when there was
alligators because some people were
getting
getting eaten and then like we walked
through one and there was an alligator
and for some reason we were there
and you wanted to kill an alligator so
you grabbed it by the tail
and it was big and you like grabbed by
the tail and then you were like yelling
at me that i needed to like bash it in
the skull
and i was sitting there like with what
like what he's like i didn't have
anything to bash it was like what you
want to be hitting then what are we
doing it's like and you were just like
yelling at me like to just hit it right
now like blah blah blah and it was like
his mouth was going like that and you
had like the tail was like this [ __ ]
giant
and i was just like what the [ __ ] kind
of dream was that it was so [ __ ]
jenny's fears about me
we will be going somewhere and i decided
to wrestle an alligator i know why she's
saying that because i said i was gonna
wrestle that goddamn alligator for the
show
probably she lived near pond well
because that sounds like some [ __ ] you
would do
yeah she wanted me to do that i did it i
can do that i know how to wrestle
alligator
i've caught small ones and every big one
but i catch a pretty big how much life
insurance do you have
they're not that [ __ ] dead
the most danger the most danger from an
alligator is the tail
yeah it'll clap you with the [ __ ]
tail yeah the tail is like very very
good
you gotta get upside down [ __ ]
straddle and [ __ ] grab the mouth and
[ __ ] hold the mouth closed they can't
open the mouth if you got it closed and
you gotta [ __ ] drag them to the
[ __ ]
side tape the mouth shut and then you
can tape the [ __ ]
arms and legs behind its [ __ ] body
but
i would just like to [ __ ] catch one
for the show and show you guys me
[ __ ]
catch an alligator i thought you were
going to save me [ __ ] an alligator is
that
i thought you were seeing me [ __ ] an
alligator i'll get it get upside down
and be like this to them alligator get
our
i mean they can get very dangerous once
they're above [ __ ]
six seven feet but
i've helped i've held baby once yeah
like five six that like five six seven
foot alligator
that's not that bad but when you start
talking about 10
foot 11 foot alligator that's [ __ ]
that's a lot of alligator
okay they're they're faster than you
think they are
all right um but you're actually better
off
going after the alligator in kind of
shallow water than you are on the ground
because they can turn around pretty
quick and they're fast they can run
forward pretty quickly
um but i'm a full-grown man they can't
swallow a full grown man
you know they might try but they could
bite some of your limbs off
there you know
but uh like they did with that dude's
hand that was like trying a few
remember that like uh that photo that
went viral a few years ago
of an alligator with a man's hand
sticking out its mouth
and a lot of people thought it was fake
but it wasn't yeah
the problem is is that an alligator
can't chew all right well yeah
they can only like bite and swallow yeah
and they can't they won't swallow
a fresh meat and they won't swallow a
[ __ ] full-grown man
what they'll try to do is take you out
into the water and roll
all right well they drown you and then
they [ __ ] you somewhere right
in the bread box they save you for later
right and then they let you ride
and then they can eat you but they're
they're usually not that combative
depending on how big they are i mean
i've
i've been right up next to oh man 12 13
foot alligator bigger than the boat
bigger than the boat and they just kind
of
they just kind of [ __ ] emerge out of
the water like them
look at you yeah they just couldn't kind
of surface up next to the [ __ ] boat
while you're out there fishing this is
lake clarko in mississippi
and we remember there were fishing off
one side of the boat we were at lake
clarko
and i heard some go and felt some
[ __ ] mist
and turn around there was like 13-foot
alligators [ __ ] huge
i said look and he's sitting there and
he goes oh yeah
him that [ __ ] he's always around here
he wants fish and you know throw some
fish and eat the fish and then [ __ ]
then disappear for a while then he'll
come back and ask for some more fish
and it he's not in the boat so he can't
really hurt you and they can't really
get into the boat
it's not really geometrically they can
maybe
they're like please please please do not
feed alligators they can't really that
very well they can't reach up
out of the water you know what i mean
they flow and there's nothing for them
to press up against
all right so i have a [ __ ]
sat there for another five or ten
minutes after we gave him some fish and
my dad says
if i got out of here and start swapping
him with the with with the fishing rod
then he left he didn't come back
yeah i mean we used to see him while we
were at the springs like canada and
stuff
yeah um tila says which is larger gator
or crocodile crocodiles are generally
larger
yeah that's different though um
biggest you know biggest thing like that
i've seen was a crocodile
i think a crocodile might be more
dangerous than an alligator well they're
jet well generally there's a lot of
different species of both yeah
crocodiles are generally larger and
they're generally more aggressive
an alligator can get big though but
alligators can also get quite large yeah
now like i said the largest one of those
i saw was a crocodile and that was at
the alligator farm
and his name was gomek and they caught
him in new guinea
he's dead now i saw him but he was still
alive
um but they've since stuffed him because
he was
kind of famous he was
um 25 feet
27 feet something like that but it
wasn't the length
of him that was intimidating it was the
girth
that [ __ ] and like i said i saw him
when he was alive he's stuffed now and
he's still like pretty impressive
when he was alive they used to have this
thing
where you would go you know you could go
look at him from up here like in his
enclosure and then they had a thing
underneath where you could look at him
underwater
and he was as big around
as maybe five
people yeah he was [ __ ]
massive now it's an alligator right no a
crocodile okay he was [ __ ] massive
got him he was old you gotta get how old
was he
they don't know they don't know how old
he was when they caught him because he
was gigantic when they caught him is
this case over
yeah okay good i want to say something
about about this [ __ ]
there's a real t there's a really good
series you need to watch all y'all need
to watch this [ __ ]
it's by this sexy [ __ ] you women
will love this dude his name is
jeremy wade it's called river monsters i
love jeremy weed jeremy wade is the real
life race bannon you know who's race
bannon
race banded with johnny quest's dad it
was the white house
he's just like he looks just like just
like every time i see
that johnny quit all right he's an older
guy in his 50s in real good
shape of white hair at least he was in
his 50s at the time he might have been
early 60s huh
i don't know how old he is he's real
good physically
i'm now now i'm going to go now and now
i'm drunk and i'm going to go look
how old was netflix and yeah it's on
it's called river see if they have any
new river monsters
and he's a specialist in fish you know
he went to [ __ ] university for this
[ __ ]
and what he would do is he would
investigate these legends that were
happening all over the world
he's 65. 65 now so he must probably
55 then if not late 50s what else was
going on yeah because he was kind of one
of our regular
shows that we would watch yeah and he's
got a real cool accent
he was real physically fit and he knew
everything about fish
and he would researching and trying to
uncover all these damn legends
legends of [ __ ] people like getting
eaten by fish in certain
ponds the monsters sea monsters
when it was all about rivers though it
wasn't seymour yeah
rivers and ponds and he goes there to
catch these things
and tries to either debunk or confirm
these legends
i mean he even went to the to the
coolant
ponds outside the chernobyl reactor
oh yeah i remember that one to catch
radioactive mutant catfish
and he did he caught some mutant catfish
he goes down tries to find these damn
confirm or deny these reports of
men being eaten by catfish
in ponds and it's just a badass series
there was at least what four or five
series of that it's called river
monsters
yeah it was a long time i mean we
watched like
the way it'll tell you they don't really
know how big fish can get
okay well especially catfish yeah
and uh some of the ones he caught were
horrifying
yeah now i've shared videos of little
hannah baron from
from um alabama that's like
ken of mine from [ __ ] mississippi
area
and she'll go down in catfish noodle and
pull out catfish about half her size
there's a trick to noodling and i know
exactly what they're doing they're
making good videos she is doing it
there are wood cuts
from renaissance era europe you know 15
hundreds sometimes even fourteen
hundreds thirteen hundreds you know
not quite the dark ages but renaissance
era
back in the honky motherland showing
woodcuts pictures of food
and they have a big old pile of fruits
and vegetables
next to it a dab cow and next to that a
catfish and the catfish is the same size
as the cow
and some people have said well none of
that's to scale that's
icons but in that same area there's
reports of
honkies being eaten by [ __ ] fish out
of the damn [ __ ]
pond so wade goes down there to try to
[ __ ] confirm or
discount all these and i look
old-school europeans did not have
fishing poles
they had nets that was it
if you couldn't catch it in the net
there was no way to catch it
except drain the dam pond and there's
there were accounts
of them draining the pond and then
fighting
huge fish and then they show the fish
and it's the size of a [ __ ] cow
it's very plausible that if a fish lived
say beyond a hundred years old that it
would just continue to get
bigger and bigger and bigger you they
didn't have rod and reel to catch it
and it was too big to catch in a in a
net
uh and netting is difficult okay um
so the only way to catch the thing was
drain the pond and that thing might be
200 years old and it might be the size
of a cow
and wow when wade confirms that that
they don't know how big they can get
because
none of these modern fish are living
towards the age that they used to live
to
and to be honest with you some of the
fish
the catfish that jeremy caught on that
show were almost as big as the cow
yeah so i i don't have a hard time
believing that at all now some of my
relatives are cajuns living in
louisiana and i remember my
grandparents my grandparents
generation i'd go down there fishing and
people that were as old as my
grandparents when i was a little kid
telling stories of a fish that we have
down there called an alligator gar
a gar is like a like an eel but it has a
head on it like an alligator
and they would say well they're small
now
now the biggest ones are about 10 feet
long
back in the 20s and the 30s they had
these paddle boats that had these big
electric
shock systems on there and they would
hire them to go out there to kill gar
and some of the photographs these guard
were [ __ ] amazing these are 13
14 foot gar and then they were saying
that they were bigger than that
so how old were these gar back in the
1800s
they were probably much bigger much
bigger you must be talking about
15 16 foot gar maybe giant
would that eat you no no
cars aren't that aren't aggressive but
they're scary looking they were scared
of them
well they are pretty scary yeah i've
seen smaller ones in the springs and
it's like even the small ones are kind
of
look like they tear you up well like i
said they're kind of like barracuda in
the sense that they're not big
but they look pissed off all the time
just a [ __ ]
long long skinny fish with a long snout
filled with razor
needle sharp fangs going all the way
down
but they're not aggressive they catch
other fish
but maybe when they get to a certain
size they might catch a human i don't
know
well i just kind of feel like once a
fish gets to a certain size i kind of
feel like whatever will fit in their
mouth is on the menu
they're kind of slow and the thing about
it like i said
you know jeremy wade he caught some
catfish on that show
that were easily big enough to at least
swallow a dude's head
or swallow a kid yeah
sammy says i watch river monsters and
now that makes me want to watch river
monsters yeah
maybe i'll like maybe we'll go find like
an episode he says
i see these clips of jeremy here on
youtube yeah that's
so [ __ ] jeremy rocks that's what
mango says
i know i love that guy yeah we're gonna
need a bigger boat
amanda murray said that oh my god we
just watched jaws the other day we did
we recorded a review of it too
he said i just clicked on his episode
about piranha he's freaking in the water
with them yeah yeah
yeah yeah well he wanted to show that
they weren't
as deadly as everyone because you know
there were all these movies about you
know like piranha which we just talked
about not too long ago
and he's like you really they really
really really have to be there really
has to be a lot of blood in the water
you're
you're yeah tammy said cows were smaller
back in the day they probably were yeah
yeah but the but the size of the fish
that they're showing
are bigger than 150 year old fish
there are every now and then a catfish
that seems to be around 100 year old
they're pretty [ __ ] big real big you
know
not as big as a shark but pushing it you
know well like i said
i've seen and even nowadays in our
depleted age
yeah um i've even been horrified by some
of the fish that jeremy pulls out of the
[ __ ] river sometimes
yeah because i can't believe how big
that [ __ ] [ __ ] is
um you know it could be and we've kind
of speculated this too about
alligators and crocodiles because
they're not really sure
what the outer edge of their uh lifespan
is like how long they can live
and it's they're not necessarily like
humans where you just kind of get to one
size and then you stay that size and
then you die
yeah they just if there's you know if
there's
environment for them to live in and if
there's food for them to eat they'll
just keep
growing yeah they're they're they're in
there asking tea to make her [ __ ]
um bloody mary do you want a drink sure
all right we have another drink
we'll talk we'll talk a little while and
then we'll we'll end the show
and go watch river monsters
well yeah that's yeah like you know we
we got through the case which is good
so now we can talk about some other
stuffs thank you so much no need for me
too
you guys gotta get around to watching
the venture brothers i know
i know i have so many things i gotta
watch
i'll get to it eventually i promise it's
just i have such a long list
of [ __ ] i gotta get through but we'll
get around to it
one of these days but yeah i just
i don't know i think i talked about this
like i said we did it we recorded a
review
of jaws the classic and it's going up
next week when i'm on vacation
and um i think one of the reasons that
i love river monsters so much because
this is some [ __ ] that i never really
thought about
i went to you know i swam in the ocean
as a kid because i grew up like right on
the [ __ ] beach right
oh you got a super chat yeah okay you
read it up yep
okay um thank you very much no need for
me
and uh you know so [ __ ] in the ocean
always scared me
yeah but then i started watching river
monsters and
jeremy wade opened my eyes to something
i had never even thought of before
that you think you're safe swimming
around in a [ __ ] river because it's
fresh water
no but no no sharks they're horrifying
yeah yeah
well now
in the south you can get hit by a tiger
shark
in pretty shallow water and tiger sharks
fresh water
in the mississippi in the mississippi
river and all its tributaries
you could be they'll eat you and your
car you can be on five foot of water in
the middle of the [ __ ] mississippi in
a damn tributary or the mississippi
river and get eaten by a [ __ ]
bull shark or a tiger shark they'll
[ __ ] bite you
they're out there also [ __ ] it's
rare it's rare it's very rare
but they're out there people have called
most of the sharks that i saw
growing up uh in daytona was sand sharks
um i saw i think i saw a couple lemon
sharks too
but it was mostly sand sharks yeah i
remember i took a marine biology class
in high school
and one of the first things they should
and i still remember this to this day
to this day one of the first things that
they showed us in marine biology they're
like look this is daytona beach and they
had taken a picture like from a
helicopter or a drone or
well they didn't have drones back then
but like a helicopter of daytona beach
here's all the little happy people
swimming
at daytona and then
20 feet away sharks
just tons and tons of [ __ ] sharks
there's tons of them
you could see them like in the [ __ ]
because it wasn't that deep you know
what i mean
and actually i've had um smaller sharks
like swim against my leg and stuff like
that just in
knee deep side deep water so they're
kind of out there like i said sand
sharks mostly which are not horribly
aggressive
and they're not huge they're usually you
know they usually get maybe
five six feet something like that which
is still terrifying
sand sharks look terrifying because they
have like a lot of their teeth are kind
of like on the outside
you know what i mean so it's kind of
like inside and outside so they look
real ugly louis said the sixth sense
retrospective was great
oh thank you and um and then
no need for me said said to louie that
tom was super on point in that one
yeah we're gonna do we're gonna do the
the
uh unbreakable oh we're gonna do
unbreakable we're gonna do the whole
superhero
[ __ ] treasure wait wait wait until
you get split because
we watched unbreakable last night yeah
we saw glass in the theater yeah never
seen split
and then split is the one in the middle
and he ordered it but we haven't got it
yet so we'll probably do that as one but
it'll probably be
after i get back from my vacation we'll
do that from the two movies that i saw
i thought in night channel m night
shamalin's
superhero trilogy
was was [ __ ] great i think it was a
masterpiece
unbreakable was the masterpiece i don't
give a [ __ ] what jay says i love that
[ __ ] movie you liked it
yeah i liked it i think it's a
masterpiece for everything we watched
some of the um you know some of the
extras
yeah and m knight said a really
fascinating thing about unbreakable
he said that i wanted the whole entire
movie
to be like the first act of a movie yeah
and i was like wow yeah that was like
actually pretty insightful
he knew he knew it was he knew what he
was doing yeah he knew he was an orange
and he was just like i didn't want to be
it you know it and it is kind of like a
regular movie but
i could totally see what he was saying i
saw glass in the theater with jenny
yeah oh this is [ __ ] awesome because
i had seen the first one already
i i i didn't know who the uh multiple
personality character was but you didn't
have to there was enough information
right there yeah because since that was
split that way
yeah but mr glass was in there in the
damn in the insane asylum
and i i really liked the mr glass
character samuel l jackson he knocked
out a [ __ ] part
he was soaking in this yeah he was good
in the face i love the way they said we
we wanted to make his hair look like
frederick douglass
frederick douglass hair and then he was
and i was like yep that's frederick
douglass on it
he didn't like it though he was like
yeah he's like i didn't like the hair i
thought it looks good you look good
yeah victor says uh his new movie old is
coming out next month
oh i wanted to remind you too they are
making a sequel to
shazam yeah did you know that
the sequel to shazam shazam yeah oh yeah
i can't wait to see that i love that i
mean it's going to be a while
they just announced it today i think
it's going to be 2023 so it's going to
be like a year mango says sixth sense is
one of the worst films ever i
had to say there's a lot of bad films
that's not one of them
there's a lot of bad films that's not
that's not one of the worst ones
yeah i mean i like other ones better um
but watching it a second time
i developed a like more like i liked it
the first time i saw it i saw it in the
theater and i thought i had seen it
since then but i guess i didn't so this
was like the second time i was saying it
i was like oh this was actually better
than i remembered i just remember being
pissed off because it came out
like i said same time as starbeck goes
and it kind of like
stamped that movie into the dust which
made me sad louis said unbreakable is my
favorite yeah that's a good one
i think i think it's great i got it like
i said i gotta see
what's called split i gotta say i gotta
see split before i have
my final verdict one of these days i'll
sit down and watch lady in the water
because some of the people like i
when it came out i just heard everybody
like [ __ ] on it yeah and i was kind
of like well
i don't know if i would waste my money
um and
from like i read a synopsis i'm like wow
that sounds dumb
but i don't know one of these days i'll
sit down and watch it because like i
said i don't like to [ __ ] on movies i
haven't seen necessarily
i don't know we'll see how it goes yeah
tila said uh yeah we have c
split dude it's great the uh james
mcavoy was amazing in that
it's on the way i mean i re i like that
actor he's a really good actor
it's on the way yeah and i said split is
real good i liked his take on
superheroes i also liked uh
i also liked the take on uh the anti
superheroes from what was it what was
the name of that for the bright bird
the evil superman that was [ __ ] cool
and then it teased another movie another
coming movie at the end of that one
but they never made the other one that
was cool too i liked it
i was laughing because victor said six
cents is sad because he's dead and still
going to work yeah
that is kind of a bummer is that that
movie i had forgotten how
melancholy that movie was i mean i liked
that about it but i had forgotten that
about it
mango said stir of echoes is an amazing
film i agree the book is good too
um yeah i remember you know what i saw
that in the theater we saw that me and
my friends on
the dollar theater graham send it
blu-ray man blu-ray
we saw that in the dollar theater and we
saw it
perhaps unwisely at like midnight
and so when we left the theater there
was like nobody and it was like pitch
black and we were like the only ones in
the parking lot that movie scared the
[ __ ] crap out of me the first time i
saw it star of echoes i didn't see that
one
it was just so well yeah we did because
we did a review of it which one was that
was the one kevin bacon and he uh gets
hypnotized by his sister-in-law
and then he starts seeing uh visions
of this girl in his house yeah i kind of
like a dead girl in his house
i don't know something about it really
really creeped me out i don't know what
it was
there's just something really did make a
big impression the hypnotism scenes in
particular like really creeped me out
that's even more so
even more so than the ghost like the
whole [ __ ] about like with
uh iliana douglas and she's kind of like
you know telling him it's like picture a
theater and it's all painted black and
like [ __ ]
the screen and it says dig and it's like
i don't know that really freaked me i
don't know why
weird things freak me out i don't really
know why okay there's another kevin
bacon movie where they were
uh [ __ ] having the near-death
experiences as pretty outlanders
flatliners
saw that in the theater as well that
movie with the way that movies filmed
just visually that's a [ __ ]
beautiful movie with all the colors and
the stained glass and yeah i've
forgotten how nice that movie looks
great movie
visually it's a great movie story in it
so it's good
that's good that's a great i mean that's
a great concept
yeah for a movie we're gonna die and
come back to life and tell you what we
saw like in the afterlife that's a great
[ __ ] concept
yeah you gotta admit we love that we
loved it back in the kids i was living
in trenton at that time [ __ ]
grantham's probably saw that [ __ ]
around the same time i did
thank you aaron great show have an
awesome vacation jen thank you
i'm really looking forward to it super
excited yeah pookie already like jumped
into my
bag and tried to go with me yeah thank
you jay peacher
what's up guys love stir of echoes yeah
me too i would like two of the new
pliskin shirts and the lar with the
large logos what do i need to do and
please tell erin happy birthday
um all you need to message me with your
sides
and your mailing address yeah and 20
won't cover that
we need to we need to print two uh
shirts tomorrow
yeah we need a print show tomorrow
shirts are 20 each
yeah so i'm gonna write that down over
there so just give me your address
right and we will print one tomorrow if
i have one yeah he wants two
i know i saw that okay you sorted that
out right yeah
but yeah stir back great
um what was i saying yeah
um but yeah so i don't know i was just
glad to re-watch
sixth sense because i was kind of mad at
it like i liked it but i was mad at it
because it came out
well i'm behind okay victor garcia sent
a 20 chat
thank you vacation fun thank you thank
you thank you
i'll use that to get into like ripley's
museum or something
i got a whole list of like all the i'm
going to all the museums i'm going to
alligator farm
go to all that [ __ ] oh um i don't know
if we said that
what [ __ ] jay preachers asked us to
tell aaron e
happy birthday happy birthday
happy birthday i likes kevin bacon film
where he was a bike messenger oh
what was that one i remember that okay
jay peterson oh it says
okay thank you very much thank you to
just get us to the mailing address and
the uh
sizes and the sizes and that you want
yeah you can message me on facebook or
instagram or
wherever okay um at least by tomorrow
because we're going to print shirts
tomorrow so
and hopefully get them sent out tomorrow
as well
yeah grandpa says kevin bacon was in
flat liners and keith of seven and keith
was in
24th maryland thomas the only two hey
that's right
you're only two degrees of kevin bacon
separation yeah
for those of you guys who don't know
[ __ ] marilyn was my ex-girlfriend
so there you go yeah brayland for 20
maryland rice cup from 24.
yeah quicksilver that was the name of it
thank you louie man louie knows
everything
matter of fact i post up pictures on
[ __ ] instagram all the time of jenny
[ __ ] dancing with her big boobs and
[ __ ] mary lynn likes them
she's awesome look at you i am awesome
yeah unless you were talking about
maryland no no no i don't know
i don't know
[Laughter]
yeah only two degrees of uh i don't know
i don't know anybody that knows kevin
bacon
i don't know how many degrees of
separation i am thank you victor
eight more dollars because alligator
farm tickets are 28. thank you oh are
they yeah okay
thank you very much i haven't checked in
a long time i haven't been to the thing
we continued to [ __ ] stream
all of a sudden the money you're gonna
be a rich little
rich woman jenny yeah david g
what's that twenty dollars cause
everyone else to donate
another two dollars thank you very much
thank you david
oh my goodness yeah it's just
yeah well like i said it's it was nice
to just do one case and i'm glad i got
it kind of covered
and then we can talk about other [ __ ] so
hopefully nobody comes in late and be
like why are you going through
about this yeah i just have
well that's another reason that i like
live streams is you're not gonna get
like rando's like wandering in here
necessarily because i don't wander into
people's live streams
thinking about a certain thing what are
you doing you posing
you were going like no [ __ ] kevin
bacon was in an animal house was he
he was an animal house must be a little
kid
[ __ ] man i haven't seen that movie in so
long
first time i remember seeing kevin bacon
was in [ __ ] friday the 13th part two
getting stabbed through the neck just
like in bay of blood
what's the matter with you what do you
think is wrong with me
i don't know alcohol
alcohol is getting [ __ ] hot man oh my
god handling [ __ ] hot
victor says we want jenny to have a good
vacation she deserves it thank you
i'm looking forward to it i'm just i'm
gonna have a good [ __ ] time
i'm gonna eat everywhere we eat
everything
we'll go see alligators look some
pirates go look some art go look at some
medieval torture
unwind [ __ ]
[Laughter]
y'all other house have fun yeah
haven't done that a long time i haven't
done that long ago she's been in this
[ __ ] office for [ __ ] five years
pretty much yeah you gotta make this a
yearly thing or something just get the
[ __ ] out of here man
yeah i probably should yeah you can't
you stand in the house too much
i mean the thing about it i get kind of
i don't know it's weird because i kind
of get
oh i gotta finish this so we're gonna
finish that like i said i wanted to
finish the cookbook before i was working
on the cookbook today
honestly it's done except for the cover
i want to tweak the cover
and the back cover i guess the
regularity of all the [ __ ] streamings
and all the [ __ ] shows i mean
even every show takes a break
we ran this [ __ ] solid for how many
years two years
yeah three years two years yeah you you
have to take a season break
yeah all right that's even if it's only
a week or so
we can pre-recorded stuff well that's
what we did this time well
and i think that this week and that's
why i'm like super tired this week
because
we pre-recorded a bunch of stuff well
yeah well because
here's the this is this is how like
[ __ ]
i don't know i don't know what this says
about me but i was like well i don't
want people to have like nothing to
watch
yeah from us like for a whole week while
i'm gone
so we recorded a show for every single
day
well closely plus the ad revenue that
too
got to get that everyone recorded a
whole bunch of movie reviews
yeah a whole bunch of movie reviews and
just all kind of [ __ ] i did a book
review and it's like a whole bunch of
[ __ ]
so we have something going up every day
even though we're not live streaming
so it'll almost be like i'm not even
gone yep
ct says that's smart well like i said i
didn't want it just there to be a big
gap and like everybody being like
because you know
i know we like to hang out with you guys
you guys like to hang out with
us and i didn't want to just like leave
everybody hanging
for some reason that comment disappeared
[ __ ]
again oh she retracted it because she
didn't she misspelled it okay well
that's what i mean sometimes people
mis you know retract their own message
because i was like why the hell did that
one [ __ ] disappear
thought the algorithm you know i thought
that algorithm was coming after
they're like you know you know what's
[ __ ] up i was giving up all these damn
national secrets
and [ __ ] talking about the [ __ ]
you know what i mean
the inner imaginations of the
intelligence agencies we got to
get rid of all these goddamn comments
say thank you thank you aaron more money
for the vacation
of the cookbook to be finished i swear
to god i'm going to vote
well i'm taking my laptop with me thank
you aaron
and even though i'm on vacation i might
finish the copper anyway because that's
like fun
yeah i mean so it's that thing you can
find a cafe and do that in a cafe
well there's wi-fi where i'm okay
staying okay
i'm staying at airbnb but there's wi-fi
all right so i should be all right
i'll get to the restroom hold on a
second you know what
i went out for my hike this morning yeah
and i saw
mr maguire and
i didn't know how to tell him that i was
going to be gone for a week
so i was kind of like i was like man
stay frosty dude
it's like hopefully some other people
like bring you some food and
you know comb your hair and stuff
because i'm not gonna be here
because i feel like he just i don't know
he maybe he does that to other people
too but he always seems really excited
to see me
and now he jumps up on the bench and
like sits next to me and chills out
which i think is really funny
but he seems a lot better like i was
petting him this morning
his wound on the side is all healed up
somebody cut all the mats out of his fur
i don't know who did it um but they're
gone now
and like i said the little wound where
the cut was that's
pretty much healed up and i feel like
today i was like petting him
and he seems like he's gained some
weight because remember i was saying
earlier that
when i was petting him he seemed really
bony and that was kind of worrying me so
i that's why
one of the reasons i kept bringing him
food and i bring him like a whole bunch
of food like every day in a little
baggie
and a couple other people have told me
yeah we bring him food too because we
thought he was too skinny
so there's like at least two or three
other people that bring him food
so he seems like he's taken care of but
i was i was petting him today
and i he's still thin
but i don't feel bones anymore so i
definitely feel like he's gained some
weight
he looks a lot healthier especially all
that hair matt's going now
yeah scott says pookie's gonna miss you
i know
it's i know that's it's like bumping me
out poking in my office earlier and
jumped up on my desk and she's like hey
i'm gonna sit on your laptops whatever
when you're trying to work
i was like whatever and uh she does she
jumps up on my desk and then she wants
to headbutt
like she jumps up and she's just like
headbutt so i headbutt her
and i was telling her i was like i was
like i'm gonna be gone next week i'm
gonna be back it's like you
you'd be good for daddy you're telling
cat stories yeah
and he's like i don't know if she knew
what i was talking about but yeah
i'm gonna miss her too well i told tom i
said well
i could skype her i guess you sky pooh
pooky pogo sky pookie yeah
yeah jenny have tom give you face chat
with pookie while you're gone see that's
what i'm saying that's what i'm saying
i was just like show me pokey where's
she at you're not gonna be gone that
long
pokey little [ __ ] like what what the
hell happened cuz when i left she was
like what the heck but i was gone for
two weeks
yeah you were going for two and she was
a baby when i came back she didn't
recognize me it took a few minutes
she still acted real weird when you left
though she was like what who the
oh i remember this dude and she came
around yeah yeah yeah that was super
funny
that was funny i said pookie what's up
and she's like
here we go
well because like i said the first like
probably the first three or four days
you were gone
yeah she was like weirded out
like she would jump up on the bed yeah
and then she kept like
looking at me like she jump up on your
side of the bench be like
yeah and she'd be like kind of making
weird noises and like looking at me and
i'd be like
yeah i'll be back soon it's okay and
she's just like what what's happening
where's daddy
but then after a couple days she forgot
but then when you came back she was just
kind of like who's this [ __ ] oh
yeah it's you
[Laughter]
all right looks like some people are
dropping off do you guys want to end the
show what
how long we've been doing this uh let's
find out i can't see it
three hours and 47 minutes
three hours of work let you guys not as
long as i thought actually no
unless you guys uh want to talk about uh
something else well probably about time
for us to go ahead and [ __ ]
skedaddle out of here victor says gather
up some of pookie's hair
fur mold it into a little cat shape and
put it in your purse
ridiculous well you know what's funny
about that
we know what's funny about that is the
other day she was in here in my office
and i have my grooming glove
so i was grooming her and i pulled like
a [ __ ] ton of hair out i was like holy
crap
and i held it up to her there was like a
little ball look at this pookie i said
this is your hair i said i could make
another mini pookie out of this
so i told her i could make another
pookie but then i said not really
because she's one of a kind that's what
i told her
okay shut it down jenny you're sure yeah
it's about time
people are leaving people are leaving
like oh my god they're talking about
cats
they can't talk about cats forever yeah
what are you talking about sure again
okay but uh yeah so
all right hopefully you guys have
enjoyed this
rambling live stream at least we got
through the entire case
before we started talking about [ __ ]
it was good joe
dude i got a mosquito bite on my elbow
and it's like [ __ ] really bothering
me
i don't know what it was all right so
anyway
i'm not gonna say i'm gonna see you
sunday because i'm not i mean i will
but it'll be on video we recorded a
whole bunch of [ __ ] ahead of time
so there'll be lots of fun [ __ ] for you
to watch mostly movie reviews
and a couple book reviews and some other
[ __ ] i will be back
for next friday's show next friday show
we're just going to talk about goth [ __ ]
goth culture the history of goth culture
because like i said i wanted to do a
topic that i didn't have to research
while i was gone
you know what i'm saying yeah uh so i
was like well i just want something i
can talk about off the cuff
so that's what we're gonna do next
friday but i will be back because i'm
coming back next friday at
early afternoon probably so i'll be back
by then
so everybody have a good week i'm gonna
have a good time you're gonna have a
good time we're all gonna have a good
time
man i'm so drunk let's go i've noticed
you i've noticed go watch some river
monsters god damn it it's 10 o'clock
you'll [ __ ] hit the green
yo you'll lay down and go to sleep well
no i still got like a lot of liquor left
to drink and then i'll fall yeah
no for real for real for real too you
need to see like a river monsters
okay you you and your old man will like
that one and you also got to see
um hannibal rising if you like [ __ ]
hand of electro movies that for me that
was the best one
i almost i actually visually liked that
movie
better than silence of the lambs it's a
good movie
i don't know i still like sounds the
lion's best sounds lamb is a good mood
you don't don't you you you fighting
with me you are fighting an argument
i said that she was awesome they're both
awesome
they're both they're just different when
uh hannibal wrote we're getting all
tested i'm getting tested
when hannibal rising came out they said
we got to have a badass [ __ ] origin
story
and they kind of did it like a batman
origin story
but it was a period piece happening in
the 40s
and it was it was badass it was it was
very accurate
and it's all uh european production it's
not hollywood
it's really good it's almost it's like a
super
good indie flick when they showed up in
that damn soviet t-34 tank and i go
man it's got a bicycle strapped to the
side of the turret i went these dudes
did their [ __ ] homework
i mean that was the real thing that's
the way that tank looked and yes they
did carry bicycles on the [ __ ] side
of the damn tank because why wouldn't
you
well you got to go get some bread you
got to get milk and cigarettes that's
what i mean are you going to take this
you're going to take the tank no they
rode a bite yeah you can't park that
[ __ ] in front of the seven of them yeah
you can't park that [ __ ] in front of
everyone [ __ ] but to do their mission
that we're gonna be here for a couple
days hold on we'll go get some
cigarettes they get on a [ __ ] bicycle
oh yeah
they said they knew exactly what they
were doing and bikes don't weigh
anything and they're very small so no
yeah yep all right all right everybody
have a good weekend have a good week
i will see you guys next friday
bye